the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess club
it was King versus King as chess royalty
battled over the boards at chess 9lx in
St Louis just 960 is an imperfect game
but that hasn't stopped the players from
turning in pristine performances chakra
mama diara had a great day at the office
winning three out of three to join
alereza farrugia for the co-lead the
young Frenchman remains undefeated going
into the final round just days after
winning the last two events of the grand
chess tour will he make it three in a
row the final day of just 9lx coming up
next
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
welcome back everybody to the final day
of Chess 9lx held at the St Louis chess
club it's been a fantastic event filled
with reels and Spills but today finally
we are going to Crown a Victor let's go
to the studio and start today's action
with Yasser and Anastasia
welcome to the capital of Chess in
United States welcome back to San Luis
here we are for Fisher random chess 9 LX
[Music]
welcome everyone here I am Anastasia
Carlow which together with one and only
famous grand master Yasser seravan I
wanted to say I'm together with
Anastasia the one and only Anastasia has
been wonderful calling the action with
you these last two days you have to
promise to come back thank you Yasser
it's a pleasure to be here with you I
really would like to come back okay good
we've got a deal and hello everyone
thank you for joining our show it's been
a rambunctious romp through two days of
Fisher random and the jockeying for
leadership position has been really
intense
but one question is crept into the
studio can our Golden Boy make it a
Triple Crown it's unbelievable but first
tell our viewers a little bit about
Chess 9lx Anastasia introduce them yeah
first of all we have to remember the
rules
um just 960 was invented by Bobby Fisher
in June 1996 originally named the
official random also known as chess 960.
named for the 960 possible starting
positions and there are restrictions
when you Shuffle the pieces on the
background I hope our viewers remember
them but still Bishops must be placed on
opposite color squares make sense king
must be placed between the two Rooks so
we can Castle long short this tournament
Players receive starting positions 15
minutes only before the beginning of the
round got it and our standings after two
days of very intense plague so your
Golden Boy alireza ferrugia his style
for the first place with Shakira
manidiaro both of them have four and a
half points have a point behind only on
the third place
have three and a half points Right
Wesley Seoul with three points so in
seventh place and then we have linear
Domingos on eights Petersfield there is
has one and a half points and Gary
Kasparov at the moment is suffering yeah
let's see the format we have 10 players
in Rapid round robin tournaments time
control is still 20 minutes for the game
was like plus five seconds per move in
chess 960 the back rank pieces are
randomized
uh and you start and position this drone
before it's round 15 minutes before all
boards have the same starting position
lucky for us yes
there will be a playoff if there is a
tie for the first place and our schedule
and today's schedule round seven begins
at 2 pm very soon round eight begins at
3 15 PM round nine will start at 4 30 pm
and then if we have playoffs it will
start at 5 30 PM evening let me press
you about the playoffs how does the
playoff work rules work yes so if we
have two players tied for the first
place then we have two games of Rapid
960. which will be which will have
different time control it's going to be
10 minutes plus two seconds per move
okay a big crank same for both games and
then if it's still tight okay then we
are going to have really nice Armageddon
game 960 Magnum game which will have
five minutes for white four minutes for
black and black winds if it ends in draw
okay that sounds very very very fun and
we're very fortunate excuse me it's a
half in studio Christian good to see you
my friend what have you got for us today
good to see you guys great to be back uh
in the studio and what an amazing event
we've had so far filled with trails and
Spills but today is finally it this is
it the championship day we're going to
finally Crown a Victor and let's take a
look at who are the players Making Waves
in this event as we are entering the
championship day we're going to start
with Grandmaster Jan naponiashi well he
had a fantastic day one as well as a
fantastic start today to a brilliant
victory in round four against Fabiano
caruana he's swindled Fabiano in that
one unfortunately for him after that
against Ali Reza and in the last round
against shakriar mama diarov he was
unable to defend just simply brilliant
play by his opponents and right now with
four points only half a point behind the
co-leaders and who are those co-leaders
well one of them is this man shock we
are mamadiar of a very peaceful first
day at the office very balanced one win
one Victor one Victory one loss and one
draw but yesterday he was on fire and
that final game in round six against
with the black pieces that was just a
brilliant attack and let's take a look
at his road ahead in this Championship
day while he's going to start off with
the defending champion who unfortunately
for him is struggling right now in this
event that is linear Dominguez he only
has two points also struggling is
Peter's Fiddler and he will be meeting
him in round eight and to finish it off
in round nine against Levon aronian and
let's take a look at who the other
co-leader of this event is and this is
the guy 19 years of age Ali Reza firuja
came to Saint Louis won two tournaments
already and he's looking forward to win
another one today but he will have a
very difficult task ahead of himself but
one thing that I'm very impressed with
this young man is his consistency he
hasn't lost a single game in this one
three victories three draws and let's
take a look at what his road ahead looks
like going into the final championship
day well against the struggling Peter's
wheeler he's going to start that off
with the white pieces one and a half
points for Peter so definitely a good
chance to start hot this final day after
that with Levon aronian and finishing it
off with Hikaru Nakamura guys we have so
many fun clashes ahead of ourselves it
sure sounds that way and Anastasia for
our audience uh lay the table and tell
them what they can expect in the round
seven pairings so seven seventh round we
have kikaru Nakamura playing against
Wesley song
and the leader alireza firozo plays
against Peter swedler and the other
leader of Shakira mamidiaro will face
linear Dominguez Gary kasparo will play
with Yan Nippon Mission an interesting
Clash is all up and down the table there
and they're fighting hard and what are
they fighting for
um yes of course they're fighting for
the great price fund
150k the total amount and the first
place will get 37 500 very very nice and
everybody walks away with a nice payday
as we're going to go to the playing Hall
see the players arriving
and yes reveal is coming soon yes
yes it looks like position is still not
there I mean everybody is walking they
passed already the security control and
they're waiting for the position what's
interesting is Gary Kasparov is going to
play against nepo but it seems like he
had been talking as our cameras rolled
in and they're going to get the reveal
position soon and we are expecting the
players to kind of go together yes Peter
and Gary seem to be Peter Fiddler and
Gary Kasparov seem to be making
the most consistent partnership
exactly yes I mean it's going to be
interesting to see today to watch the
game of Gary Kasparov because of course
he's suffering these days and he
published lots of many tweets in his
Twitter account explaining a little bit
what happened to him right so those days
yeah
yeah players I saw that and Declaration
was getting seated so to be honest maybe
he's alone because the other players are
still motivated right yes so he just
decided to put the pieces
and by the oh here we go
all right
you can see okay let's do the reveal
Anastasia Shuffle what the back rank for
us please yes let's see the number and
the number is
838. okay wow Bishop's on A1 that means
Pawn on B2 is pressing forward uh
Christian break it down for us what do
you see in the reveal uh
the the problem pieces if you will so I
don't have the position on a my board
but the first thing I'm seeing is
actually that Queen on B8 maybe we can
see it on your board or maybe we can
still look at that the problem is I'm
seeing that Queen on B8 ready to capture
the pawn on H2 sure you can do that but
let's not forget the Rook on G1 is
actually defended already by the King on
F1 and if you do start with this move C5
C4 let's say after you take on H2 I will
have ideas of potentially and I do think
I have the board right now so for
example C4 c5n you go for the capture
I'm seeing Knight to G6 Rook to h8 is
already a big threat to trap the queen
so I don't think you can go for this
Pawn but now this might be very very
interesting and if you do go Queen to H5
to try to run away with the queen you
have Rook to h8 after that I will pick
up that pawn on H2 and you might have
some problems so you cannot immediately
go for this Pawn on H7 in terms of
problem pieces well this Knight looks
quite nice I'm probably going to get it
to G3 of course I have to worry about
ideas of H5 nevertheless without the
Rook supporting that H Pawn H5 is not
going to be an easy move to make so this
night I like it the Knight on C1 I like
it as well the bishopone A1 is perfectly
placed ready to uh be opened up fiance
and create a very strong battery on the
long diagonal after B3 or maybe even b4n
in fact I was looking at the engine B4
is the main move right now B4 seems to
be the strongest move and it makes a lot
of sense you're uh helping your queen to
get out not via the C file not via the
B1 H7 of diagonal but the other third
rank after Queen to B3 also this Knight
is going to go potentially behind the
pawn and most importantly the respawn A1
is going to be protected look what
they're looking at
immediately C4 castle and Bishop to C2 I
don't like this castle by the way
and uh now he's trading at the ponds
there this can definitely not be good
for a while
well so far uh nobody's uh making the
Mateen three combinations that caught my
eye right wait which one is that the the
Checkmate in three I'm seeing all right
C1 to D3 okay uh Knight D3 to E5 okay
don't look now
nobody's defending the central Bond and
it's not only a royal Fork it's just a
smothered check so what are the problem
pieces in your opinion I could not
necessarily see a clear problem well I I
saw what the players were trying to do
what the players were trying to do was
uh deal with this bishop too you saw
that the bishop was going to C2 but
while you were talking about grabbing
that H7 Pawn yeah yes or no uh Anastasia
wanted to point out that this is move
b2b3 opening up the bishop so it means
that you Rook you know for the moment is
not going to go to h8 you've got to make
I will go E5 though
yeah and then and then everybody runs
home right
pointing to D7 alone thank you Anastasia
look at you see the training is working
it has your ideas
and then we'll try to are you actually
using that pawn oh course we I'll give
it to you oh boy I will give it you're
so nice actually can we have another
not yet I'm not going to take on H2
let's try something like Bishop to G5
okay look at this you see he recognizing
our understanding of uh weaknesses upon
weakness and stuff he's going after
hours I have so much compensation here
you guys are completely lost no way Jose
we're two thumbs up we got this in the
bag I cannot believe you we're already
counting the 37 500 that comes with a
perfect score
okay I like very much you move E3 you
know to be sure that the queen can go to
E2 in case yes yes that was the main
idea I'm sure
yes and there he is Ali razor as he has
throughout the entire event no no he
wasn't even he works by himself he
thinks of his opponents as Rivals and
therefore no reason to give them any
insights so much his explanation why
he's doing it if you if you missed it
actually yesterday you definitely should
check his interview which Christian made
with some he explained why actually he
stays on his own and he doesn't really
play this position with other players
right
he's a very competitive young man yes
let's just put it that way and you know
these players know that they're not
going to be able to even scratch the
surface in 10-15 minutes exactly and he
knows that as well he understands that
no he says chess is already so
complicated game in 1000 years they
didn't find out what to do how can I
find it in 15 minutes right
one one variation that I'd like to show
that I've seen the players looking at
c2c4 attacking this Pawn on H7 and then
what a lot of the players have been
doing is Catholic castling on move one
wow how cool is that I remember it
happened once with Nakamura Carlson
match during the Carlson match both of
them the first move was castling
castling
but look at this you don't see mate in
one thread on the second move so often
so we're threatening made in one and I
saw them playing uh this this crazy
position right up to this moment and uh
well I don't know I think they actually
gave up on this idea
because it came back yeah I think it
becomes just a week also not even Bishop
to E4 but maybe Knight to G3 try to set
up that pin we're not worried about G6
and yeah I can understand
exactly you have to be careful about
that Rook H1 yes yes yes yes yes Rook H1
and opening up the long diagonal and
then you go E6 and then you can already
see some sacrifices on Jesus actually it
shows that white has some Edge from the
very beginning right of the game so I
think after Knight G6 uh you have to uh
yeah I mean you just you just got to
protect that part on nature I don't want
to protect that you don't you you really
don't sir you keep trying to take that
pawn I told you I don't I don't care I
really don't care B5 I'm going to go C5
C5 C5 B5 is an idea as well I I like D5
and then when we I I really
we should explain
we'll talk softly and slowly and carry a
very big step again we'll get into this
again I have so much compensation here
yes okay just worse I mean you have
proof exactly exactly we want action
Knight B6 okay
I know he starts to defend his partner I
probably shouldn't do that I probably
should give you the pawn on us okay now
by the way look what we've done and look
what he's done everybody the bishop on
A8 I heard the cries the Bishop from A8
was so loud
you guys are bamboozling me
because it's two against one you know
let me meet the Jedi for five seconds
let me think for five seconds five
seconds while you're thinking I just
want to mention something I paid
attention to Fabiano Carana today he was
analyzing with his other team with Nepal
Wesley so he knows why I think it's
because he's playing against it yes so
he cannot unless with the same teammate
because and now Levon was analyzing
together with linear Domingos yes yes so
I mean I see some difference okay
there's some teams and by the way as we
were coming on the show Anastasia you
were sharing with me some very very nice
comments that Gary Kasparov had made on
the Tweet uh one of the things he had
said is that
he's not prepared at all in Casa is
cruel to those who do not give their all
100 exactly and he said however that
he's happy that he's made quite a number
of good moves but unfortunately a key
moments the results speak for themselves
but uh that he can play these guys but
you were mentioning Christian when
you're not consistently playing when
you're not you know in that competition
all the time this is what can happen I I
think that's it I'm not really concerned
about his preparation I'm mostly worried
about his level of activity and that's
zero pretty much exactly yes he's also
busy with so many other stuff exactly
really important problems for this world
put it this way yes yeah you we had
dinner on a few occasions with Gary here
in St Louis and he explains to us his
schedule he wakes up at seven o'clock in
the morning and usually he has about 10
email messages as he's preparing to go
uh to what did he say uh Berlin
conferences yes it was one after the
other after the other people are next
morning yesterday interviews he gives
like every day he gives interviews he's
working on behalf of Ukraine
Ukrainian appeals I want to say and all
of these humanitarian missions that he
goes on it's non-stop absolutely so
that's why it's it's really difficult to
concentrate on chess during those days I
would put it this way also but for him
he loves it he loves chess and you know
if he gets this opportunity to play
it's very hard for him to decline but
again Christian if you're not
sharp I don't know even how to say it
and I feel it's almost the same not on
the same level but definitely very
similar for Peter Peter nowadays he's
much more of a commentator right he
loves commentating he does that
full-time he doesn't play as much and I
think we can see it in this tournament
for Peter as well but one thing that
these players have made quite clear is
that they're enjoying a lot the process
of analyzing the process of looking with
fresh eyes right at new positions from
move one not playing 20 moves of theory
this is something that all of them
really enjoy and you can see it on their
faces too you can yes yeah actually yeah
sir what is your favorite type of Chess
so actually I mean variation of Chess
right okay I love uh chess variants and
essentially when I was a kid I was
raised with house so I became a really
really Bug House Fanatic in fact I think
it it lent itself to my enjoyment of the
game itself like it as I became a better
Bug House player I became a better chess
player really so it helped him to do
everything everything just everything
and uh I feel today that I Still Love
Bug House I made my own variant uh sjs
and with sjs I introduced two new pieces
uh the hawk and the elephant and that's
incredibly fun I've I've taught it to
Lavon and other players that that that
enjoy variance Jeffrey Zhang and
it's a challenge it's really a lot of
fun how about yourself what's your
what's your story no because of course
it's it's amazing chess actually I've
seen you yesterday play and it's really
actually a pleasure to watch you how you
do it I mean it's just amazing one day I
think it's gonna be a different event
here yeah this type of Chess and
Christian you're you're a big bug house
player I've seen you and Fabi it's like
c squared is formidable you've uh you've
felt our power yes sir you felt our
power you and Alejandro were trying to
team up against us and I told you it's
not going to be competitive and in my
version at least it wasn't well what was
uh your version well it it all it's not
about the result it's about who is
counting the results and according to my
account it was very favorable
uh no but seriously bug house uh here
even Magnus by the way when Magnus comes
to town he'll he'll jump in for a
session of buck house MBL as well I've
actually checkmated Magnus and buck
house oh it sounds like a problem but I
haven't seen him play as often not as
often he's losing too much
the rules also differ quite a lot
exactly if you come from Europe you
cannot uh place a piece with Czech or
with Checkmate in American in North
American buckhouse you can do all of
those things yes every day we're
fighting for the rules for example for
one hour and then at the end
exactly exactly the bug house is a a
really really a favorite uh variant
that's very popular and I remember doing
summer camps with children and we would
have a bug house during the summer camps
and I turned to the camp director Don
Schultz and they say Don if all I did
all day was allow the kid play Bug House
they would go away saying that was the
greatest they just can't be ever had in
their life they're just having a lot of
life and it's very social right like one
of the things that attracted me as a kid
was just uh going to the club and
playing with my peers that was my
favorite thing to do Bach house at the
same time you're creating a team you're
creating an atmosphere that rewards a
very good team and making good
friendships and all of that the social
aspect of it is very very appealing and
they are off just as you suggested c2c4
was met by C5 inviting I really don't
think
Peter's inviting the capture go go for
it yes take the pawn let's see let's see
if he if alireza Will Follow a
recommendation or not that's a critical
moment exactly yes I'm sure Christian
now is very very nervous
for me
sometimes you just have to be true to
your most inner self
upon yes Knight to G6 Queen to H3 and I
would just say hey you know prove prove
me wrong and sometimes it happens most
of the time I get the win look at this
yes
oh Christians defibrillator
defibrillator our friend Christian
our friend Christian is in trouble we
are going to lose our friend we need a
defibrillator
Tyler come on
okay okay but Knight G6 is an automatic
it's no well the strange thing is maybe
they missed it maybe they didn't notice
it said someone is hanging action
I could see him he didn't think that
that's even a possibility he was
analyzing with Gary and he was like yeah
you cannot take the pawn on A7 right
a little bit surprised by the delay on
playing Knight G6 because you you want
to trap the queen and I was thinking
that's an automatic why the big thing so
here we have tried
B3 no p45 okay it's too much maybe
maybe but B3 just to keep the bishop
pardon me to keep the Rook Tethered to
the pawn for that moment so rookie h8 is
the big threat b2b3 stops the threat and
says to Black okay what are you gonna do
and we know we're gonna need B3 so this
is a kind of move we can play and uh
what about before yeah that's what I
thought before it's interesting E5 let's
say but then you and then you play Queen
h35 I'm like to stop the idea but
there's no threat so I can take the pawn
on B4 oh you can take the phone okay
right so sorry for that no it's okay
it's okay the training
yes
it's working now the one good thing
about Knight G6 is it does stop our
Checkmate in three idea the Checkmate in
three why it doesn't 95 now
improving ah a diversionary tactic okay
so we still have that yes um I'm
thinking
uh B3 E5 anyway I'll just step back and
say okay uh go ahead and deal uh with
this guy why because it suddenly
occurred to me is if I make B3 move it
suddenly occurred to me that there was
this idea that the bishop
very nice like if I went here the bishop
could come here
and oh I got 9.5 I apologize
I was about to say that now our Queen is
trapped right but Knight F5
turns the tables once more I'm still
Rook G8 to h8 I got Bishop G7 but it's
unclear if he turns the tables right
because even after that Knight F5 yeah I
can go E5 right yes I take on H6 and I
go Rook h8 oh my goodness what a wow
take on H6 and you still
wow so it's very unclear it's it's a
wild position I have to say and that
that too is what is so attractive about
uh chess 960 is you're getting unique
positions like this reminds me of the
position of Levon yesterday against the
car when he could have played that move
Queen to B6 followed by Knight wave five
but his Queen was still getting trapped
with Rook to A6 right that's really
similar to that but that was a beautiful
find for sure do we no we do have played
B3 B3 on the board yes wow
once a broadcast every broadcast we get
in this quick shot these guys are good
they're following her yes they're
following our suggestions we have to
admit yes it's true uh what else is
going on on uh some of the other boards
I think Hikaru versus Wesley by the way
my pick Wesley so they're they're they
are underway they played a lot of moves
uh Christian yeah and I'm not even sure
how to call this position a benoni
structure not really right but this is
how they started off C4 Knight G6
defending the pawn on H7 Wesley doesn't
want to give that pawn B4 immediately
taking as much space as possible so
Hikaru definitely values space and the
openness of his pieces very very much
Knight to G3 B5 C5 D5 is the position
and by the way the engines are screaming
right now they're saying white is
completely winning already wow
to my eyes at least it's very strange
because it doesn't seem like you made
any big mistakes right I mean you are
having full control of the center you
can potentially open up this bishop
after the move a D4 so it doesn't seem
like there's anything coming your way
immediately nevertheless the engine
really hates it D3 oh there went the
advantage E3 was the move yeah good luck
trying to understand why why is the best
movement the move right let's say castle
castle and then let's make a normal move
right V7 Knight to D3 and I guess right
now the idea for white is to actually
put the Knight on D3 get F4 going open
up the long diagonal for the bishop and
after that take advantage of the fact
that the Knight on G6 doesn't have any
uh positive prospects in the position so
definitely an interesting approach
nevertheless none of that happened
Hikaru took a different uh approach e D3
followed by E4 with the sole idea of
playing against the bishop on a setting
up this closed path for the bishop on a
quite an interesting approach
nevertheless
and now the question for our audience
identify these socks who do they belong
to I say live on me too you're an
influencer uh yes
finally we we got one right yes together
we did it
it's always the fashion you know why I
was confused I was confused because
normally also his shoes are also quite
bright exactly well we know who's got
the shoes who's got the easy the best
ones
a big game what's going on between Fabi
and Lavon
well that one is pretty crazy as well
all right let's take a look at that one
a very different approaches by all the
players uh in in previous positions
we've seen very similar approaches and
uh today's position uh position 838 did
you say yeah they uh they they've
definitely taken different approaches
and here we see this very nice Tempo it
feels like you want to put the queen on
B2 right then create that battery
potentially even look at F4 right now
and looking at F4 I like that approach
as well is the big move that I want to
make this this is uh the the one piece
that I want to get into play as fast as
possible okay uh can I
cry you can't yeah and I think that's a
very nice uh it's a little Annoying
Tempo because if you have to defend the
pawn like this maybe I can get
everything
and then
but still you can take on F4 maybe it's
not
yeah yeah it's it's a no I want to get
the knife on D3 so perhaps after F5 what
if I try to go Knight D3 here right
David three yeah I'm trying to follow
nepo he says it's all about development
and and I do tend to agree with him so
that in this case you you don't
sacrifice no no sacrifices Knight to H5
yeah
wow um
crazy position this is this is a the
king does not have a lot of uh Palace
guards I'm just looking at a crazy line
where I really how do I put it uh play
all in for the attack I'm thinking this
queen is lurking on a good day let's say
I'm gonna play badly for just a moment
put the Knight away and on a good day
you know what I'm thinking right this of
course a knight of three or four years
nice yes I do have a lot of puzzle rush
you do have a lot of pieces I do
swimming around my king so I'm always
worried at some point yeah this night
where can it go help help I'm not
exactly sure but there's not a lot of
Palace guards just something to keep in
mind how about uh Gary versus nepo now
now nepo is as you stated at the top of
the show he started 4-0 but two
successive defeats against both with the
players who are now co-leaders by the
way yes uh not nepo off his perch what's
happening Christian in Gary's it does
seem like Gary is a little bit better at
least visually right I mean you have so
much space in the center and it almost
feels like at any point the radical D5
and completely shut off the bishop on A8
also at the same time opening up your
own Bishop on A1 which is once again one
of your most powerful pieces in this
position setup so definitely from a
practical perspective having more space
having these options of nullifying the
bishopone A8 for black it does feel like
white has the advantage in this one
great thank you for that somehow I
managed to mess up
we're going to go over to your board
because I've met managed to mess up my
uh
you have it this is the position right
now Knight to E7 was the last move
played obviously the intention is to go
Knight to C6 hit the queen and then
potentially follow that up with Bishop
to F6 but once again you always have to
be careful about E5 D5 and all these
potential uh advancements in the center
by white I really like what white is
doing right now right now taking a look
at the time still 14 minutes 30 seconds
for Gary that's pretty decent definitely
not falling behind too much and as I was
saying that that he wants to go Knight
C6 he went to a G6 wait a minute so how
did he got rid of the Knight on h8
and got the other one okay Knight to F4
so this was the trade Knight G6 Knight
F4 exchanged this Knight and then get
the other Knight to G6 yeah it's an
interesting approach
it was a little confounding there
because wait a minute you know but I
thought that was a really clever uh idea
of Peter because it took away the the
oomph behind F4 F5 you mean of Wesley
pardon me Kasparov was going to play
f4f5 yes and Wesley did play this idea
with sorry Nepal nepo Nepal yes yeah not
Peter
um yeah Knight to G6 definitely a good
one I understand the wolf of F5 of f4 is
present so let's reinforce that oh
Knight to H5
why not also not only that I'm
reinforcing the move F4 but once again
I'm coupling the idea of playing D5
shutting off your bishopone A8 with the
idea of pressuring you on the G7 Square
this is it Knight to H5 seems to be a
very good move and right now the
pressure is going to be on uh yeah to
find a defensive setup which is not easy
to find you probably have to start
looking at trying to trade off pieces
Knight to F4 trade-offs and more pieces
and try to survive those type of
positions definitely not going to be
easy especially let's say Knight takes
F4 Queen takes F4 I can see a rook
lurking on the third rank Rook to E3
Rook F3 Rook G3 once again this is the
the key Square I'm looking at the pawn
on G7 you're gonna love it we've been
waiting anxiously for you to return to
the game between ferrugia and Peter
because everything all according to our
notes I don't know I mean we have
analysis
we got this we got this Ali Reza says
look I'm in first and I'm currently two
pawns out what do you got for it
yeah sometimes you just gotta throw the
gauntlet down and and uh
play chess exactly exactly how are we
doing on time now now look look he's
looking for the time I'm looking at the
Gonzales what I got for the two pods
I've got a lot of time I'm trying to
find some positive aspects about the
position and there's one I'll be six so
opening the bishop
B6
is this bishop on A5 I I kind of
considered this as a defensive reaction
seizing the defensive as this Pawn is
under serious attack
now honestly but but you see actually he
was ready for moves like Rook d8 yes so
he was not afraid to give up this Pawn
on D2 so instead of B6 maybe black could
try something the group did but uh
probably it didn't work that well he
must have been afraid that it would only
resulted in a trade of that was why
Peter but you're right with the move B6
a couple of things have happened the
night
is well that's one square that's not
going to d8 is not protected so we don't
have to and the bishop isn't coming back
the The Bishop's on a one-way ticket
that is the problem and remember I was
trying to do something very similar I
was putting my Bishop on G5
yes with the same idea I'm looking at
that square right on G5 the problem was
that you're playing E3 and then you are
hitting that Bishop with Queen to F5 now
the problem is after the bishop comes to
A5 is there's no more especially coupled
with the idea of B6 there's no more to
d8 right and that is because you are
setting up so much pressure on this Pawn
on e4 right maybe actually castling just
give up this dito pawn and you can also
no I don't know I'm thinking about it
like I'm going to predict much even to
give you responding it protects H2 maybe
on a very very good day I'm not
suggesting that I'm reaching for the
pawn quite yet but that King is still on
f8 Square so a move like F3 to open up
the f file after castling yeah it's good
I think this is going to be a very
interesting game uh what else do you
have for us Christian well I was still
looking at this game and I was trying to
percent also with the engines and
actually the engines are giving this as
a completely winning position for white
you have
explained about green Rook to D1
depend upon on D to keep all your pawns
alive you have to be greedy in this
position and I have to say the more I
look at the position the more it makes
sense with this Pawn already on e4 this
bishop is not doing as much as I wanted
it to be doing uh the bishop on A8 also
the bishop on A5 now that you play the
move B6 seems a bit out of touch with
whatever is happening in the position
and I'm looking at White species except
the Knight on C1 right all the other
pieces are having an active role in the
position this Knight is not only
defending but also ready to go to F5 and
put a lot of pressure on the pawn on G7
coupled with the activity of the
bishopone A1 this queen is ready to come
back swing back potentially on G4 and
once again look towards this G7 square
but also to towards the E4 Pawn so I'm
definitely looking and comparing the
pieces in this position and it
definitely seems like white is just
pretty much completely winning at this
point right the training is going well
but I'm a little worried I lost control
there when he went like rookie Wanda
deep he wanted like getting his
explanation of why you should defend
your plans he plays it he played it nice
but the training is definitely working
with this one okay I'll tell you that
much the force is strong
um look at this game between Lanier and
Shaq because all the pieces are still on
the board no trades I've seen like a lot
of trades in the Fabi versus uh uh Lavon
but I'm looking at I I want to I want
white to start getting the pieces off
the back rank where should this night go
Anastasia from suwane yeah because if
you go so if they're not a chance to be
three then no no no Bishop yes so 92
probably yeah but then I gotta worry
about the bishop landing on D2 right so
if I go 92 uh there is this uh trap Rook
that I have to deal with
so if I go Bishop B3 then I'm prepping
for Knight D2 but again I
right I mean
even though perhaps you can take on D5
but that's not a pawn the problem is
that pawn on D5 is so well protected
right so how does Shaq and Tango himself
here it's not easy
so using the right words yes sir
untangling because right now the best
move is D4
and that untangles your pieces because
now finally your Knights
if it works once you see it you go wow
of course that makes perfect sense
exactly but until you did not mentioned
it he played Bishop G4 yeah it wasn't on
my radar but D4 would have as you say
gained space opened the bishop but more
importantly just get ready to play
Knight D3 and Away you go Bishop G4 on
the board everything's on the board
actually kind of symmetry the difference
is this Pawn is on C5 Queen d8 Lanier I
like what he's doing better than uh what
Shaq has been doing well right now
actually Lanier's position looks very
much like a chest position right yeah
all of the pieces maybe except of this
configuration of the rokoniet and on f8
so if you do have some time get the
queen out of the way go with the Rook to
d8 and the other route to f8 that's an
option but right you can make use of
what you have right now in the position
potentially hint at ideas of playing the
move F5 later on in the game of course
not immediately Knight E2 as you
suggested now in this position I mean I
got to tell you right flat out I I love
as black playing the move D5 D4 yes it
does take away the pressure that I have
that look what it does to this night and
to this bishop this bishop will have to
spend some time
uh and I like the space but we'll see
what Lanier's approach is I wanted to go
back to the Ali Raza game because he did
play Rook D1 look at this oh he did and
97 and wait a minute
do I see yes yes yes yes yes take it you
have to take it I mean why not
Peter is really we know him as a very
nice guy yes he's very nice and willing
to share yes is somebody willing to
share his pawns yes
but why not right right Bishop to E4 and
it also feels like it's not only that
you're taking a pawn but finally your
knight on C1 once exactly has this D3
square right right exactly no the
question is okay let's start calculating
Bishop takes E4 Bishop takes C4 okay
Knight takes C4 okay then something
comes to age too yeah something let's
say queen things right okay
now the the problem with Rook D1 is I
can't castle that way again not anymore
so after Knight C3 I do not threaten to
Castle
but can I borrow yes thank you but I
think neither four well that's okay yeah
Knight F4 I'll I'll in this case
Queen to G4 let's take the other Knight
to G6 like 96 right and get rid of
bye-bye
just get get rid of that by the way this
bishop could really become offsides if
it's not not doing anything in the next
5-10 moves it will really uh play a
passive spectator role interesting game
it looks very good for our co-tournament
leader Shaq doesn't look that good at
the moment but everything to play for
let's see Gary kasparos as a Sherry's
position is very interesting look at
this nice
wow
you don't see that very often important
a white Pawn on D6 but on the other hand
it's not exactly disturbing uh Black's
development like blackas you can see
this bishop on d8 is
okay
and this bishop wild yeah the queen
could make room for so at the moment the
space isn't
you know putting black under lock and
key all right so should we just simply
go wild let's go G4 yes I think about
this four actually G4 but but like it's
like you're opening all everything for
your opponent too yes
I have to I have to agree with you guys
I mean you need to have a computer with
you
but maybe it's really dangerous let's
check just if F takes G4 F takes G4
whenever you do that I always I am
looking at Bishop to E4 you really want
to take with this phone ah yeah okay
okay first one issue in the in and it's
not a positional issue it's a Time issue
Gary down to five minutes uh FG okay if
I if I roll with the punches I've got
Bishop G6 on tap I've got Bishop E4 on
Tab it looks good for a while so Queen
and Bishop they stay I mean they're
positioned very well but it's no
checkmates yet yes no threats but Gary's
clock and I I know nepo has been playing
the whole tournament
in easy easy so what time does nepo have
but to play move before you really need
to be sure what you are doing right
that's a that's an issue that's actually
more psychological maybe it's such a
good middle move yes nepo has 15 minutes
and 30 seconds oh one thing that nepo
does very well is he thinks on his
opponent's time yes he really is trying
to delve deep into the position if you
look at him well maybe not right now but
he's definitely always keeping a very
focused posture but I also heard him
telling me like why did they make this
move so fast they had so much time here
and like what's wrong with you just
think a little bit so but Gary needs to
start making movies
dropping down to his last three minutes
not good against 15 minutes I mean from
the Practical side of it when it just
feels like your material down it doesn't
matter if you have a great position but
when you're having five times less time
than your opponent right that's a
problem absolutely I mean an app and
it's also that pressure of knowing that
you have so much little time
you you guys have looked at G4 I propose
a different approach yes maybe bishop to
G Bishop to E3 gift me the pawn you're
gonna play Rook G7 you're not going to
play G4 I'm gonna go H4 and I'm gonna
give you a pawn
and I want to see just exactly I think
there's G4 on the board guys G4 G4 no H4
H4 H4 on the board I made the same idea
actually similar ideas yes exactly I was
thinking that if the king
can be safe on oh Rook G7 immediately so
Gary spent a lot of time playing a very
committal move and immediately
immediately it's unpleasant actually as
if I expected you to play this move what
took you so long that's the way Nepal
plays I know that's the way Nepal is but
isn't Gary just simply doing extremely
well
G5 Bishop Bishop because I was thinking
that my dark Square Bishop trading them
was actually a plus for white well he's
following up with your ideas yes yes he
played it the the resulting position uh
Christian what do we make of the of this
position position
do you want me to use the engine please
by all means
get our silicone friend involved black
is better black is better black is
better actually after the trade yes
Queen C5
Queen C5 I want to go into our name game
with you because maybe spawn 8 is
actually very nicely placed not only
that but even without the Queens I will
still have some very tremendous
attacking possibilities coupled with the
fact that my Rook is already active on
the G file I have options of opening
that g file with the move H4 or F4 and
then you cannot move this Pawn right if
you run F4 open up this bishop H4 is
going to come open up the G file and
you're going to get checkmated on the G
file with or without the Queens on the
board so it's still very dangerous it
feels like for a white right now let's
see what and by the way they're going
into that position right now now will he
play Queen no and it's not the only move
like okay it's not the only one you can
just play normal moves such as Rook to
C8 or anything it doesn't feel like
white actually has a follow-up in the
position I don't know maybe like Queen
F4 maybe it was some ideas even though
yeah
yes yeah
yes
yeah no maybe uh Gary overestimated his
position I certainly did uh I thought
that this was a position where the
bishop
was going to play a role but it looks
like for example if I by the way King H1
is on board yes King H7 and Gary is down
to his last minute and 30 seconds I'm
looking at Rook F2 I'm looking at Rook
on E8 to G8 Rook to G1 defending at the
moment I would be very
uh oh is there a Checkmate no you can't
yeah he can't I wasn't thinking that you
could sacrifice a rook uh but not not so
fast not so fast so we've seen a couple
of fast moves but
for a second it hasn't updated yet maybe
we can see the bird's eye view it's
going to help us so King H7 I'm
expecting Rook F2
Rook G8 Rook G1
what have we said yes
so Gary would prefer
keeping his Rook on F1 okay but now you
have to start thinking about ideas such
as Rook G4
Rook G4 wow that yes yes
now my idea is that you're blind and
you're going to take on G4 for example
yeah
deep Deep Thoughts with Christians
considering can I take on C4 and just
sacrifice The Exchange and say that I
have a lot of compensation due to my
active Bishop on A8 you know truth be
told Christian you have a lot of
compensation doing that but you had a
lot of compensation before probably yes
exactly I mean it's it's an idea I just
I
of a little bit more worried that one
day the Rooks will reposition themselves
the king will step off of this diagonal
and then the threats of H4 and F4 will
be too strong he played through G6
interesting move now so he's kind of
prepping ah and then H4 H4 I see so he's
also yeah also by the way Queen no Queen
foreign
just to
say uh Queen F4 can't be played because
then your move Christian Rook G4 is too
strong which I think he probably missed
and okay
is there a trick yes
foreign
G6 okay and the problem is you cannot
take on H5 I have a rook H6 that is true
that's
that's a really play six yes it's just
no that is not uh that is not a
competition you should not play by the
way he said to Gary gave him a reprieve
he said Rook G4 is not that great
but now Gary has the option of Defending
The Rook on G2 and then Rook G4 becomes
absolutely yes yes
immediately played it's sort of like
okay okay I I I
transgressed but uh you forgave me
okay this is this is crazy Queen C5 now
and okay
don't like how Gary has played this I
thought
he's getting himself in a little bit of
a a tangle okay I don't know if Gary
actually saw this but I checked it to be
the engine Queen F4 G4 was actually bad
yes because of Bishop to E4 no
maybe he started shaking his head
inviting him to play this and after
Bishop E4 is now white who is better
yes yes wow an incredible trick by it
yeah
why did Trap by the former world
champion okay two seconds we have to
check it like Bishop E4 F takes C4 sorry
I I he did what I suspected he would do
it I think a really good plan is to take
a king walk put your Bishop on C6 tuck
your king all the way to B7 and then one
day these moves H4 and F4 are going to
essentially sack the king
carries no time no time 15 seconds don't
you want he's trying to transfer the
other G2
to what's purpose that's a good question
also right now Queen eight three Queen
A3 I like that move the move I'd really
like by the way wants more is to put the
bishop on C6 I've got all the time in
the world uh as black white has
literally no threats in the position you
know sometimes I'm looking at such moves
like Bishop F5 and the E6 this type of
ideas but not working
you're a very dangerous woman yes
look at this you want to sacrifice their
pieces that's good that's good and then
like D7 Queen B8 I mean all these ideas
are like go go go that's another reason
why you should play Bishop C6 to have
that T6 Pawn under control right yes
maybe right I like this move Bishop C6
Anastasia again yes it's not so great
yes
it's never who thinking okay it's I
think only good news
but it's it remained seconds I mean less
than a minute
not that much happened in the early Reza
still much better for nursing some extra
funds whoa lots have happened though
whoa whoa whoa whoa Peter just played
Knight F5 is that a threat of Maiden one
that not that one not in one but in a
couple yes yes Knight E3 made three well
it's at least a queen yeah yeah Rook
takes D1 Queen takes D1 Knight E3 that's
true whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa what
happened to our Golden Boy he did take
the pawn
he took another one too he took four
pawns by the way is firusha down to his
last minute
no I think 50 seconds you are right and
he's like
King I think the King has to go to E1 to
sidestep this devastating threat yeah I
like them all like very nice perfect
well in this case it's called survival
never mind
survive run the problem
isn't it maybe two at times
wow that's why would he invite yes the
queen queen oh then he can Castle
um oh my gosh haha
they named Castle oh what a trick oh my
goodness that would be amazing I I think
he will I I think that sounds good no
moves
[Music]
but by the way guys there is a just 26
seconds right now wow his decisions will
have to be bullet fast
well it's extended Castle he's got to do
it in the next 20 seconds and the stuff
no but actually it looks a bit dangerous
because look I mean
queen and Rook everybody all pieces are
attacking yes I mean I don't really see
how yeah
you're moving into a huge attack yeah so
like the one good news I can I can offer
alireza is that he does have the move
Queen C6 which will serve both offensive
and defensive purposes I can cover if
I'm forced to play G3 sometime down the
road I can cover the light squares with
Queen C6 I don't think I can force you
to do that so I was looking at Queen to
F4 okay and I don't think you want to
play G3 if you go G3 I have Queen H6 and
some seconds
yes this might become problematic right
correct but I think you can go H3 right
which and I'm not convinced I'm in time
to sacrifice it's all about about
whether you are able you have time to go
night somewhere and then a sacrifice on
G2 right
now that was the idea was to encase
those nights started hovering around the
G2 complex yeah
but uh hmm uh I was thinking another way
maybe Queen H oops sorry it was supposed
to go to H6 so the idea was not to
occupy the four years the square of four
yeah exactly but uh
it was so tricky
it's from my Bug House days
yes it does feel like black has to do
something immediate right correct how
about this idea Knight E3
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
uh Knight E3
actually I bet you dollars Donuts uh
that's exactly what Peter's thinking
about
that's a nice crafty move okay let's
check what if you take the night
by the way Gary Kasparov has lost as
Napo on
unblemished Heat wins and loses that's
all he does no draws no draws never
um
man don't draw
then we have at least oh do we have at
least a draw
because I can sacrifice not convinced
not convinced I have a 97 and that
covers all the checks right
so Rook takes F7 no no I meant that
black has at least a draw oh black yes
yes yeah yes black for sure has it which
means that Knight E3 is definitely a
very very uh promising possibility and
it's probably a very important move to
make if you don't do that yes no but
when you see all pieces next to the king
and the other white pieces are somewhere
else at this moment something is should
be there right yes but of course it's
just Theory you have to find the moves
right that's striking while the iron is
hot when you have a material
preponderance on the king side as does
black two nights right now for Peter and
by the way of the other co-leader is
actually winning his game so we'll take
a look at that in just a second but
let's stay with this one for the moment
all right
um big moment for our co-commentator
Willie spot 93. we naturally I I'm
seduced by Queen H6 I have to tell you
guys Queen H6 and H3 and Knight F4 and
that's why I think Knight E3 is a
difficult move yeah because all the
other checkmating threats in one move
right they're so appealing you're I mean
look at this you're eyeballing this guy
you've got Queen G5 you got Knight I
mean it just feels like blacks
pieces are swarming exactly so but now
what if I go Queen D7 guys that's
another checkmating threat of my own
exactly also the Knight on F5 also the
night so if you don't Checkmate me after
Knight takes H3 I will have to take that
I'm forced to take it right but maybe it
sounds like Knight H3 immediately yes
yes I take a coin yes and then I go
so I've got at least Perpetual but I'm
not sure you have but I guess you do
have yes Perpetual yes I mean what you
go to yeah
[Laughter]
I've always said about Christians his
courage is unmatched okay you know what
guys I'm gonna go to F3 no
okay I do believe that Peter is actually
looking at 93. Christian give us some
ideas of what we could expect after this
very forcing let me take a look at the
engine right now Knight to E3
is the best move in that position
the only move that maintains an
advantage no the only thing you're
knitting in this position is to actually
include your queen into the attack and
create your counter challenge so now
Queen D7
well I mean he couldn't I mean it's such
a seductive idea you have to go for that
King F3 guys come on
here we are now it's Queen D7 for sure
no it should be five
years
yeah guys he's defending H2 and he's
thinking Queen C6 will defend H1 sorry
let me put that on the board
on and
where's the man they said ferrugia does
this defend I think so wow wow if it
works what a great concept because like
Queen G4 Queen yes so it's not possible
what if Knight did four days there are
some checks already Quincy Aid yes but
you have to take on H3 if not I take on
f4a and then I'm gonna be like what two
pawns three pawns up wow like Queen G5
we're the defending Knight as well in
the facility
five check first let's see okay
15 seconds for Ali Reza no that's that's
smart Queen G5 actually King H2 seems
like the only move King H2 what's Knight
H4 Bishop G3 of course if Knight H4
attacking the bishop and threatening
Queen H4 or something finish for Queen
B3 23s you cover on the third Rank and
oh my goodness also Queen A3 is an idea
to just attack the pawn on C5 as well
extra Rook
a king to G1 okay Queen to G4 check
okay but now I can please
four yes I can repeat once at least
foreign
um that might be a three-fold repetition
and I think Peter like oh yes he takes
and now it's a it's a question because
if you think it's a draw right so can we
go Queen five seconds no he takes okay
a great job Peter They're laughing both
big smiles big smiles as our commentator
let's jump to the game of chakriar
versus our defending Champion Lanier as
chakriar he's wonderful he's a pawn up
and he's got these beautiful pawns to
fight against Shaq is winning this this
is this is all but in the bag
yep he's got an A4
it's all going swimmingly for our
co-leader
okay there's going to be a race at some
point so it's not I don't see it at some
point I will go King G4 and try to take
a Leo on the king side yeah I'll I'll
drop back I'll I'll drop back
yeah I think my knight can do it I can
do the job by itself I'll go Knight C3
push push but for example so when do you
go King F2 he did it already immediately
Bishop C6 this is where the Knight Will
ruled the bishop by being able to play
on both complex of squares yeah no this
looks good this looks pretty much
dominant at this point exactly it feels
like King E5 maybe try to drag your king
back to E3 and then try to go backing F5
but exactly I'll get in oh H6
okay
D4 let's go he's done it
I think it's time to just wait as black
maybe H5
just give white the move if you play D5
then a king a future king E5
he waits with those moves so Bishop he
just moves the bishop Bishop
so he's saying okay show me the progress
how do you make any progress in this
position
so what happens
you can see it on the board now
sorry H6 was the first
moved it with them oh sorry yeah the way
after Knight C3
I thought he played D4 right away but
okay I'm wrong
that's fine D4 what did you do after D4
something and then before and there is
before yesterday
yes yes okay I'll just refresh my board
and we're up to date and now he wants to
put D5 and C6 in some variations yes
maybe not D5
maybe even with a blockade
but the more pawns get traded yeah
absolutely
and if you go King to F2 I still have
that H1 Square yeah I'm thinking
I should redirect my knight to the E5
square and then what
well I'm I'm hoping that I'll make it
like a zook swung so I can at least
drive your king into some passives
he just went I'm not sure the most
directive way possible finger six
do you win it after King D7 if he could
play like you know on the dark squares
okay you're threatening Jack and let's
go King to seven okay
and now perhaps let's go H4 let's try to
exchange well be careful I've got the
threat of Knight F7
Knight F7 is simply winning because I'm
forcing the pawn into a fork if you go
um pardon me G4 I've got check and let
me take it yeah that seems to be waiting
yeah a table base just jumped up what
does it say about the position table
base says unknown
[Laughter]
and if you try to go C6 I have the H3
Square
so you take on G5 you go C7 and then I
have Bishop H3
eventually you will have Bishop H3 ready
to give up your Bishop incredible
defense wow incredible defense D5 looked
rushed yes the move d4d5
a lot of nervousness there oh Shaq just
said you know what I see your defense
right Bishop H3 it's still not over yes
what about Knight B5 now
the finance is free yes yes what a
knight C7 that's a seven even yes of
course and actually now with the oh he's
going for it can we go for this
for this Bond
G35 now with the King on E5 you just
feels like this should be cool
so bad Bishop G4 perhaps
Bishop C8
now if this game ends in a draw
that means that two tournament
co-leaders will be tied but can anybody
catch them
the top right now exactly yeah
because he won against Gary so it means
that's right Five Points all three okay
and then also Fabiano is lurking in the
back if he manages to win which he
actually is just winning I think we're
going to see a review shall we call this
game a draw there's a resignation in
Fabiano's game right now oh Fabby is
Wanted let's just see the last few moves
I mean chaotic position as both players
have protected past pawns but the move
Knight C6 to D4
and Fabi is only half a point behind the
leaders and he's lurking
and by the way Hikaru went down to
Wesley
wow wow
I don't hear any draw do we are this one
maybe also firusha versus Peter was a
draw
that game was so crazy that I think
everybody deserved the
full point in that game but while we
were talking now there's no more deep
thought
how did that happen I I don't know but
it went but I think it made Black's
defense easier with this bishop
patrolling this diagonal and the King
always ready to uh come forward and by
the body language of Lanier he thinks
the same yeah that is just like looking
around you know as like okay why are you
still playing right I have an easy draw
by the way three decisive results only
only yes it felt like all of them
it's only doing on time though I mean
can somebody actually flag in this one
uh we don't have a good will you no I
see eight seconds on chat eight seconds
five seconds make a move
he held it for well until one second it
looks like cannot believe it okay I
don't know
I remember one ice cream serious
questions I'm going to go to G4 okay but
that's okay
remember once even took a few seconds on
his clock and he was giving against Gary
he played it he couldn't
take his hand to make the movement she
was waiting and made everybody nervous
yes
the B7 I don't know I like C6 has to be
played right now go for it yeah but your
black king is so close to the pawn now
that's okay
will you be able to defend it with your
king
Maybe
yeah I think yeah King F5 really five uh
now wow wow wow uh
so let's say King D4 can G4 yes by the
way that's the idea I believe Shaq is
down to his last five seconds right now
and I don't think he has to make a move
three seconds wow
redirecting Knight D4
but okay we can deal with that we're
happy about that King D6
I don't think that's going to help his
case right
you can even way six now Bishop Bishop
G4 why is it I like [ __ ] Space six just
because it
yes okay it asks a very Salient question
you have to oh nice look at this nice
trip yes 19669 before yes
you spawn very nice
about night no no no no no but I think
that was the last trick that was the
last trick no but look at the shock huh
all the time he's trying to find some
tactics he's looking for something how
can I win that's all these guys
played with two two seconds on the clock
oh no now how much time does no but wait
a minute I can take on F5 now take on a
five take on C6
what that's a draw okay but uh hard to
make such decisions but you have to make
it no oops he had to avoid Knight E7
check
he had to avoid 97 checks as well we
have three all right
right now you're C7 wait a minute 97 is
coming isn't this just winning I think
so and there you see it the knot right
now
wow the nod of the head is the giveaway
oh my goodness what a Miss
we do not have a tie for first yes
because I won the game exactly and he's
four for four and uh in his last unless
foreign
Soul Leader and we're down to our
Championship rounds two to go
penultimate championship game round
coming up well what where did it go
wrong where did he well under a
Christian well I mean you can think on
F5 I think that was the the key moment
that was the moment right here of course
yes
this was this was the calculation that
can throw you off you take on C6 and now
you start calculating this right are you
in time yes you are because you go King
to F7 and you know that this position is
uh F6
that's going to be a draw of course uh
he probably started seeing ghosts he did
not trust his intuition I can guarantee
you he saw Bishop takes F5 and he was
calculating but he only had five seconds
on his clock so he had to make the move
so fast unfortunately for him he played
this move King to E5 at Bishop to E6
story and this was the key moment Bishop
to E6 just allowed C7 now you cannot
defend the E7 square with your king you
cannot play the move King to E6 and get
close to the pawn with the move King to
D7 with the bishop on C8 you would have
been able to do uh that unfortunately
you're not in time to do that after
receiving seventh game is over wow
beautiful beautiful offense I have to
say by Shakira he created problems all
the way until the end and finally Lanier
cracked Under Pressure he was rewarded
for his persistence and as we get ready
for our standings tell our audience what
what offers there are at qbtq Anastasia
yes we have today the t-shirt is in the
standard button-down black shorts sleeve
on a shirt featuring the chest 9lx logo
on the front and the Saint Louis chess
club look on the back available in your
size
have you tried it no I'm anxious I mean
I worry today oh really I had one
it looks it looks wonderful and there's
plenty more swag also at the World Chess
Hall of Fame such as do check out Q
Boutique and we are ready for our
standings we have a sole leader
Anastasia
who just won the game against linear he
has five and a half points uh and Yani
Promise by winning this game also he
jumped to the second place he is on has
five points together with alireza
ferrugia and then we have Fabiano
caruana with sworn off points on the
first place Wesley saw has four points
three and a half same Mexican
Petersfield there two points and then
linear Dominguez was two points Gary
Kasparov unfortunately lost the game so
it's still on 10th place exactly and our
pairings for the penultimate round
Anastasia so Wesley Seoul where was
absolutely then we have linear Dominguez
facing Gary Kasparov Peter's feeder will
play with Shakir mamidiaro Peter is in
good shape already that draw certainly
uh give him more confidence for sure and
then will play against alireza Fusion
the leader one second place Maria and
Hikaru Nakamura will play against
Fabiano carono big big clashes and as we
go to break we invite you to take a
break yourselves I mean too much
excitement going on over here and we'll
see you on the other side
thank you
may have heard about St Louis's
world-class Museums Art History Science
even magic
you may not know we have an entire
Museum dedicated to play with a 10 story
slide and a ferris wheel on top
don't let all this family fun Slide by
you
[Music]
do this Saint Lou is always exploring
anybody
[Music]
thank you
thank you foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
and welcome back everyone we have
standing software around seven chakra
mediaro is leading in the tournament
with five and a half points
they share second place with five points
and then we have Fabiano Carana on the
first place with four and half points
Wesley Seoul follows him with four
points Lebanon and Hikaru Nakamura with
three and a half Peter smithler two
points linear Domingo's two points and
then we have Gary casparo suffering and
our pairings for our penultimate round
eight Anastasia do the honors so round
eight we have Wesley saw playing against
Yankee and Eric Domingos Gary casparov
Caesars video will play against the
leader of shakui armaniaro good luck to
Peter can Peter spoil the streak yes
big matches there as well and we're
getting ready for the reveal of the new
route the new position pardon me that
they're going to be playing in this
round eight and shall we shuffle them up
let's see what the new position might be
here it comes I wonder if they're
analyzing music I think so okay what do
we have position seven year once so
Bishops in the corner that usually means
we're gonna see a B3 B6 or B4 B5 problem
piece Queen on G1 how are you gonna get
that into the game uh Christian take it
away what do you see as the tasks the
players are going to have to solve that
is uh the one big task that I'm seeing
in the position for both sides of course
is the Queen the queen on G1 G8
respectively first of all if the queen
wouldn't be on G1 I would be able to
Castle so with the queen on G1 I don't
see short castling happening anytime
soon because you do want to play
potentially G4 get the queen out but
then you will not want to short Castle
because the king is going to become weak
with the spawn from G2 moved to G4 you
don't want that so this King probably
will go on the other side and Castle
long AI this is the big problem a very
uh harmonious potential development on
the queen side I can see B3 C4 get the
Knight to C3 behind the pawn on C4 the
bishop goes to C2 and then I do long
Castle so I see quite an easy
development on the queen side definitely
not as easy on the king side G4 Queen to
G3 but then where is the Knight going
the knight from H1 definitely quite an
intriguing position and after G4 for
example I was asking where does the
Knight go sure if you put the queen on
G3 if you put the queen on G2 the
problem is you will have to face ideas
of B6 and the opening of the light
Square Bishop on the long diagonal so
the queen is the big problem in this
particular position all right and for me
uh I see that the A2 Pawn is undefended
so I and the A7 Pawn as well therefore
so I'm attracted to the move F4 and oops
that's supposed to be an arrow went
across the board it got Midway something
like B7 B6 and then I'm thinking this
bishop is a good Bishop so I would
probably want to play E3 and I liked
what you were saying about the
harmonious development of castling Queen
side I want to put my Bishop on F4
potentially even recapture with the pawn
onto B3 so let me just put some moves
let's do the same B5 let's do the same
E3 let's go let's go and we're going to
get some position like this this is the
position that I'm aspiring for now you
can do
exactly now I can do the castling the G4
what Christian mentioned open up uh the
possibilities for the queen development
um it's going to be uh
if they go into these types of position
the Christian will be a long-winded
battle it won't be like the E4 E5 D4 D5
clashes and I can easily see ideas of D4
potentially for white with the idea to
go D5 and right if the center open yeah
it feels like half the participants are
working and working with one another
sticking together it seems like and I
was actually curious to see whether
Fabiano and Levon are going to rekindle
their let's say romance right the
program after they took a break in the
previous round I don't see actually
where he would have been oldest mean all
this time yeah hikara seems to he's like
the succeeds all the way in the back I
just took his jacket off they're his
okay
but you're a very disappointing result
for him because I think right now he
understands with only two games to go he
does not have a good chance of winning
actually I think he's completely out
almost out mathematically almost out
yeah two points behind Mama diarov right
now is going to be very difficult to
catch up he's playing against Fabiano
and Anastasia what uh what do you
um
give to shackriar that he's got four out
of four to the
uh have a good night rest what's
happened to him he's a different man oh
yes for sure I mean probably it's
already the third tournament he's
playing actually it's been a marathon
for him and um I know that he he really
let's say he gets his self-confidence
back when he feels that his brain works
well and he like he enjoys playing so I
think he finally found his way and
perhaps a lack of opening preparation
here also helps him I mean just he needs
to play creatively and enjoy himself you
know playing chess so that's what he
mentioned also during the interview
um he had said that something remarkable
actually played 300 games for the years
and it's an unbelievable number it was
just like wow non-stop I think it's uh
because of covet you know he suffered so
much staying at home during college
period I remember we were to chatting
with him from time to time during the
times and he really couldn't believe
that all this was happening so now he's
enjoying back at the board sitting in
front of her opponent and boom there we
have it F2 F4 or F4 F5 I think it's on
board maybe not the five but F4 is the
first one I think he was also terrified
with this moment that he played two
legal moves in the first event and it
took him a couple of weeks to come back
to normal I think he needed to recover
from that uh shock i i t i teased him
that there was a best price for
the best cheater he was like I won I won
I won something F4 B7 B6 so kind of
going into those very that that mood
that I mentioned now you don't have to
play E3 right away you could play Knight
C3 at least intimating that you were
going to play for E4 likely that will
produce F5 as well something like this
F5 and this is where I was really
heading like I was I want
it's very funny with Fisher random chess
me personally I want to commit my king
early to a Castle's position we just
witnessed Perugia for Juan who had
delayed Castle castles castles Castle
until the very last moment and he made
his remember what happened
yeah I like uh you know having my king
secured and then I can face the middle
game with confidence Christian over to
you and what what games caught your eye
a very cool battle is happening between
the two Americans Nakamura versus
Fabiano right now because Nakamura
started off with F4 Fabiano responded
with B6 we've seen this typical move in
a lot of other games depending upon on
A7 and immediately Hikaru played the
move F5
cannot believe it let's take more space
right
approach but are you falling behind in
development right now F6 B3 and now we
have this move G6 immediately
challenging this expanded maybe over
expanded upon on F5 this one well it's
not going to be a tame approach that's
right given the structure and what we're
seeing right now happening on the board
I don't think this one is going to be
very tame and if we follow it up with G4
just go ahead and put that dude foreign
yes
where would the uh the likely path go
well a lot of interesting things can
happen right now
Knight F7 Knight D6 at least to my eyes
make the most practical okay uh sense
right because you want to Target this
Pawn on F5 and put as much pressure on
it as possible also E5 I do believe that
you want to have this idea of E6 and
creating even more pressure in your back
pocket right unfortunately if you go E5
that's not an option anymore so I do
prefer the move Knight to F7
nevertheless G4 is not on the board he's
still thinking it's a big decision for
Hikaru G4 I mean you are over expanding
on the king side well I think that the
move F5 is a very typical reaction of
what
um chacriar said in his interview
yesterday that when you're white you're
trying to get an advantage and sometimes
you play a move like F4 F5 and instead
of getting an advantage you get a big
big disadvantage and he Shakira said I
won four games if that makes sense with
the black pieces and lost one with the
white pieces something like this and it
was sort of like F4 F5 is maybe a
demonstration of an overreach by Hikaru
by the way a very important game between
those two players this game between
Wesley so and nepo boy I tell you that
that looks like our prep the two players
are bringing it and what about Lanier
and Lanier and Gary very different
approach by Gary Gary did play B7 B6 as
a reaction and maybe Lanier kind of
channels his inner Nakamura with the
move G2 G before preparing F5 not
immediately and E7 E6 you know if there
wasn't a night even though exactly there
wasn't a night on H1 that would contain
some Venom uh with the move E7 E6 that
looks like a fun game going right there
uh but look at what's happening in the
Iranian game guys guys
whoa C2C whoa exactly it just it just
blowed up
by the way you mentioned the other that
you would have taken this bishop on F3
with the pawn remember you said that
maybe it's not a bad idea to take a ice
Bishop I I was concerned that well not
concerned I like to give my queen
especially
uh more Pathways to get into the game he
recaptured with the Rook
and
I don't know about this move C4 help me
out Christian is that another one of
those
overreach kind of moves do you do we
really need the move C4 as well it does
seem like right now uh black used to be
preferred I mean you're making so many
weaknesses in your position right that
scored D3 whenever you're going to go
long Castle well the square A2 is going
to be a problem Knight B4 might be on
tap for black so it's definitely looking
loose for white right now and you're
coupling so many ideas and it doesn't
feel like they're very cohesive in this
position because there is no F3 where
are you going with that Rook on F3
exactly on G3 that's going to get hit by
the bishopone H4 correct you might have
some problems Knight H4 is also an idea
right now not completely uh
wrong either yeah um I don't know I at
least from a visual perspective it just
feels like black is closer to finishing
up its development also the structure is
much more compact for black uh let me uh
Play The Devil's Advocate here I'll take
upon I assume you want to recapture with
this Knight I'm not sure 100 sure and uh
because my Rook as you mentioned kind of
lacks a square here yep
and actually maybe we can show that
because
this just goes to show that C4 is not a
tremendously good move because if you go
Rook H3 boom Knight D3 is coming on the
board oh surprise surprise harassing
so I think so many pieces are involved
it's what we would say ding dong
[Laughter]
uh yeah we're gonna have to play Rook to
H3 and it feels like uh well one move
kind of interesting threatening the
castle short offering the pawn but
because the king is still here
um I'd be reluctant to grab this part I
love that move and I was trying to well
take on H7 just for example because I'm
seeing some very nice variations you
want a castle Bishop Queen G6
if you want to attack The Rook no no I
want to go Queen G6 okay I will tell you
why so you have to go to H3 right and
I'll be page four
oh my God
my knight D3 is coming wow and Knight F3
too well if you take on H4
do you have that we have Royal fork and
we have family Fork Royal Fork is king
and queen but a family Fork also with
the Rook do you have that uh no I don't
have I didn't know expression and no it
is nice by the way I don't know if it
works
it looks fun it looks fun it looked
inspiring that is for sure
um nice challenges going on here by the
way we've got uh we've got uh some some
skin in the game here we we uh that is
to say Christian and I uh chose Wesley
yes
[Music]
I mean how does he even have any well he
won against Hikaru in the previous round
which that took him to who I believe was
it four and a half four and a half he's
I don't think it's not bad yeah
it's doing a little bit better I think
no
if I remember correctly Fabiano has more
points so I'm here
don't tell me you're you're you're not
kidding
against legendary Grandmasters to quote
you it's legendary absolutely legendary
but still yeah they're competing I'm
still hoping and rooting for my uh but
if I don't have more points then it
means yes it has four points once again
a peek at the standings so you see the
far because half a point more compared
to Wesley's Soul so it's uh he's on the
fourth place and Wesley's still on Fifth
Place Wesley one and a half points
behind it that's a lot and he still has
some chances to win the tournament even
you can see that if he wins two last
rounds very decisive important rounds
then he even can win the tournament it
means a lot to go his way though let's
say so with the white pieces against Jan
the last few moves seemed like an
invitation to a draw for if I see that
correctly I have the same feeling here
uh I am seeing a number of reps going on
here I think that's it I think that's a
draw right um
and there's the draw
yes
ah yes I think you can also offer a draw
you can yes you can offer yeah there's
no more no draw offers absolutely in
this ornament yeah really okay I think
not that draw offers are being offered
or accepted by the way the decisive
number of games is amazing close to 80
let's jump to I'm not sure that so
players remember that you know exactly I
don't remember the rules no no no no no
uh Lavon versus uh
alireza we thought with the move E6 E5
that
um Levon actually was the one in a bit
of trouble he did not capture the pawn
on E5 and make those moves with the Rook
he instead just said Knight C3 go ahead
if you like you can gain more space my
idea will be that in the future Maybe
not immediately but after castling I'll
play G4 and try to undermine your
structure
and uh Knight C3 on the board uh
Christian is that uh
it's still a very complex battle I think
also even after before there's nothing
immediate nothing immediate no that
wasn't happening in the position okay
it's still a very fluid uh Center
potentially I can go E4 as black I can
close it up I can take on F4 and keep it
open or I can wait with the pawn on E5
and I think that's probably the best
course of action program he did play
Queen E6 did Ali Riza and he's thinking
you know I can Castle short too uh if
you by the way
Lavon is committed to castling long his
Rook has already moved obviously so he's
so Ali raise it like for example let's
just put some moves down for a moment
castles on opposite sides but now I go
D4 D4 yeah I mean this has been the move
that creates the most problems almost
for blacking so many instances and I
think we're actually going towards that
variation whoa isn't that problematic
with a queen on E6 how do you defend
against D5
um and if you have to exchange one of
the pawns and then get out of the way
then I feel like my Rook on F3 finally
has something to do I go to E3
potentially to H3 as well it feels like
my pieces finally are better than yours
as white
I think maybe four first and then
castling maybe after after a while it
makes castling Queen E6 we do have Queen
E6 so Queen is six and then E4 and then
is that analysis or is that the same
position they have that they played
straight into the variation that we were
looking at wow I was about to suggest a
different move now before but the queen
is six because six castles and D4 I was
thinking the same as you Anastasia so D4
takes on D4 I don't think he took yet oh
no so he's maybe considering Knight D5
let me just refresh my board because I
can't believe
yeah he's talking on D4 he took on D4
already I think he's considering Knight
D5 which makes some sense if you think
about it
how long do we think about it probably
not for long
because I do like winning the tempo
right I I think that's the idea I mean
after 95 you're not going to take on E3
yes is he afraid of Knight takes F4 no
yes
it's a pawn but I go D5
listen listen to your oh my God your
friends your Mentor your
I remember only the song listen to your
heart listen dear listen to your heart
you are too too hungry too hungry greedy
hungry for for the power yes sir he's
paused let's go crazy one because I bet
you he is concerned about uh Ali Reza is
not going to take on F4 come on guys no
no commentators cursed yes you be
careful you be careful over there Knight
E5 look at this I'm a pawn up and I've
got the initiative well he took on D4
let's wait and see here it comes I have
to say Ali Reza has been extremely
greedy in this format so in the first
game of today round seven he certainly
was yeah I can see Knight takes f4 on
appearing on the board because the
otherwise what you said makes perfect
sense D5 rookie one rookie three great
Harmony in the position for white you
gotta you you gotta make white page
what's happening what what what they're
talking about something Yes actually
Reza is complaining for whatever reason
maybe there's some chatting going on
you're right the guys who made a drawer
yes are congratulating themselves on
their brilliant play there we go kick
them out kick them out
Christian how do we let him compete in
these competitions
you're in a good shape yesterday
I think we need to get you in yes see
this is the danger I shouldn't be too
accurate King B1 immediately by the way
not even not thinking about rookie four
yes exactly he just said forget about it
King B1 I trust you yes deal with the
Dual threats so
D5 you have to deal with that Queen H6
is one of the Waves I think F2 is
another one right
90 I didn't realize I had a choice I
think 92 might be I don't know if it's a
good choice but Knight T2 is an option
as well it feels like that Queen is
going to get trapped it feels like but
how you can do it yourself some chicken
like I don't see it the thing is to open
but also I feel like can my queen
somehow get trapped out yes
it can go everywhere and you're somehow
you're you're running and uh
well even here I've got great comp but I
think I can do better by the way Queen
H6 was played the Knight H3 came
immediately 93.
Queen H6 getting out of Dodge Knight H3
whoa didn't see that one coming what is
Knight H3 by the way okay the night Rook
at three that I can see that I've just
helped
well I I can feel that I'm helping uh
White can I just like you mean black
yeah black is helping no no The Rook
really but isn't it he took on H3
where is that road going I mean I will
go Queen G6 yes almost half a Tempo
let's say because I do have F4 ideas wow
G3 and now I hide I don't have seven
but aren't you like really afraid that
that died because I can challenge you
with the Bishops
you know that Bishop hasn't moved yes
yes I forgot the Bishop's been lurking
and it feels like your king actually
gets weaker the King on B1 right right
that that is a good point I think what
if white didn't have this Pawn on G2 it
would be better yes now Queen on G1
right that's absolutely yes but
unfortunately it's a pawn could it mean
that no Lavon isn't thinking about G
takes H3 is he oops I hope not
okay
disappeared uh suddenly it disappears
and she takes but she takes I go F4
right
at four nah I hate my Pawn structure and
of course I'm a pawn down as well
with the pawn
the commentator's curse yeah what are
you talking about this is brilliant
your comments are the the Ali razor will
never never
take the vines but G takes H3 to open up
and maybe play Creative I mean what is
this obvious moves like that Bishop H4
that's creative
yes that's crazy no well you're not
allowing the route to come to G3 and
you're developing
but really why not
Okay so
the essence
yeah I wrote to F1 but I'm probably
going to give you that F5 Pawn because
of player F4 Queen G4 then yes probably
yes yes
but the the problem is making a good
point this is
uh Christian's making a very good point
that if we do take twice the bishop has
a dual purpose it stops Rook G3 but also
protects for rookie one
future
very intriguing positions what else is
happening I think black is just
completely dominating right now what is
happening in our tournament leaders game
as we jump to Shack rear that one is
Wild is it that one is wild and it does
seem like shakuria is having a pretty
nice position right
so much space in the center the king is
still and it's not going to get canceled
actually anytime soon you cannot Castle
on the short side and I'm not sure if
you want to Castle on the long side so
Peter also was influenced and guess what
Peter played F5 it was a hikarus
it was preparation yeah okay and wow
after D5 Shaq looks that's an imposing
Center
Queen jumped out I think black is simply
better I think Shaq is taking over the
initiative right now and soon but look
at the C4 E4 making sure D3 Square will
be like 95 is coming
right whatever Fork you can imagine
I mean if this night was on C5 life
would be gold
um this looks really good for Shaq but
he's gonna have to do something Bishop
to B4 Rook to d8 what's what what are
what does the engine uh evaluate the
position is it looks good for for black
the engine is uh recommending Knight E5
in fact
just go for it just go for it I think
yeah I think he has to take you probably
have to take this Knight D3 is going to
come and you might be in some yeah but
now I'm crying about other issues that's
one Rook takes F5 is another one
and the Knight is actually not jumping
to the center anytime soon you don't
have an id4 you don't have Knight F4 you
don't have a good way to activate your
knight makes sense also what's the
Knight on H1 still doing there
he's in the way actually the night uh uh
on H1 very very deep I think 95 is a
very unpleasant one double punch yes I'm
not weakness no and in this case uh I
think the problem is we were just
jumping in anyway and just you know
causing a real accident along the C file
and horrible yeah this guy and this
looks okay chaos for 25 guys I think 95
was played really yeah yeah
and he has to be because there is a
couple of contenders lurking in the back
I mean I know it's not stopping anytime
soon exactly right neither is Nepal it
seems like right so right
he needs to win games if he wants to
maintain his Edge
well I mean unfortunately in the grand
chess tour he was the defending a
champion in Bucharest he had won
previously Bucharest with a very nice
plus three undefeated and everything
went wrong for Shaq in Bucharest he
didn't have a grand chess tour he didn't
have a good performance in the grand
Chester but we know he's a brilliant
player as we've seen but I think it
shows also how strong granted stories
like every every player can be first I
think I'd be the last one I mean that's
Maxine yes yeah he came into St Louis in
clear first and looking just to secure a
Podium placement just barely barely hung
on to that third place first and second
went
right out the door and uh 95 that's
that's a great move Peter uh Under
Pressure let's just jump to the Gary
Kasparov versus linear game because it
seems to me and I
uh Gary has played some very creative
chess he doesn't
end up typically following uh the lines
that like for example
you've just played the move E3
let's go and Gary C5
and let's see where we standing here
we caught up
by the way breaking news of course he is
playing Lanier so let's put this in
perspective uh but he is ahead on time
for the first time in the entire
tournament an opponent has less time but
again it is Lanier if there was going to
be an opponent of the tournament who had
less time it would be Lanier Dominguez
and I think I think would say
Gary's doing Gary's his name was
slightly better is that fair yeah no I
mean why not it's still a complex battle
but okay I think black is slightly
better at least visually okay a big big
big clash between top American players
Hikaru Nakamura and Fabiano and this was
the early F5 punch yes and when we left
it we kind of left it around these parts
so let's just quickly get caught up that
Bishop H5 check that is a funny check
uh and white
the two Bishops
and he's maintained his Pawn on F5
for the moment anyway
but wait a minute
talk about cohesion we can get these
doubled Rooks and end up playing Knight
G4 and Knight H2 or Knight F5 even or
Knight F5 because using the fact there
is a pin exactly with the work on once
we've got the doubled Rooks what about
those two Bishops this guy
is well it's kind of stuck in mud you've
got a a good Blocker on F6 uh our
feeling is that Fabi might have tricked
Hikaru in this position and maybe
fabby's for choice
um the engine is not agreeing with you
okay good the engine is saying that uh
Hikaru is actually better in this area
how to expect only because of the fact
that he has more space on the king side
Rook to F4
the engine was proposing Bishop to D1 in
fact Bishop to Bishop E1 and just try to
preserve your space Advantage like that
and so after D1 you see the other route
coming to G8 it doesn't feel like white
is better right right I I don't feel it
right I don't I think what you wanted to
do Rook to G8 is to just play moves such
as potentially E4 and calm the position
down defend upon on F5 okay and then try
to kick that Rook uh from G5 at some
point it's not easy to play like that
you have to do you want to do something
active and this is exactly what Hikaru
is doing Rook to F4 Rook to G8 he's
looking towards that H4 square and
activating The Rook the problem is you
also have to tend to your F5 pawn and
that's the weakness that Fabiano is
focusing on right now well I mean Knight
takes F5
right now Anastasia said take advantage
of the pin let's do it let's go I'm
assuming Rook F1 to maintain the palm on
on F5 and if Hikaru is intimating he
wants to play for Rook H4 he's going to
do it like this but let's try to get
aggressive now let's go 95. exactly
is that I I'm still kind of stunned when
you said that the engine prefers white I
was like wow I thought black was doing
pretty darn good it prefers white I mean
that's almost an overstatement they
prefer white but it's a very balanced
position plus 0.5 in chess 960 in such a
complex battle without
um well many known factors at stake I
mean I I feel like it's very difficult
to say that white is better so it's
balanced balance Fair balance yes I
think it's just a bad expansion let's
just jump to the Lavon uh Lavon played
G2 takes H3 and that Ali Reza has been
nursing at extra Pawn that he captured
very early in this game it's an extra
Pawn but it almost looks like two extra
parts it does because the structure is
so
ugly
sc4 C5
okay yeah he tries to open this diagonal
yes
that's a that's a strange move you know
for some reason I I really liked having
the vision parked on H4 just to you know
maybe drop the queen into D2 on a good
day and he did however Play Bishop D6 C4
C5 I think Lavon
scrambling to get out of this game if he
could get a draw here I think he would
take it I mean he's a pawn down and I
think the conversation lies with the
black side exactly I take on C5 and then
I try to exchange the Bishops with
Bishop E5 right it's actually
interesting why we couldn't take on the
five before I think you can think I mean
those three right all right there is
this I think with the scary Queen the D2
reminding reminding white that uh he did
one and then I can go on the second rank
as well C4
C4 oh exposed the king a bit and if you
do go Rook F1 then as Christian said
oops
it like yeah so the F5 Pawn was
Untouchable but here you were you're
about to say after C5 trade the Bishops
and just enjoy your extra Pawn
makes sense to me I mean maybe you can
take on F5 but it does feel very
dangerous oh let's take on F5 right now
in this in this moment well if you don't
do it now I think it's you're not gonna
do it ever right and uh if we drop in
no no you go Queen A5 I think it's made
by itself sorry yes it's very so easy
yeah this is this is ugly and I don't
have King B1 because of Queen Victoria
The Rook so Queen is a one is okay yes
it's lost it looks like
yeah I would I wouldn't want to have
anything anything to do with this
position and they are playing quickly so
let's just uh flash back and forth and
catch up with them but it does feel guys
like Shaq our leader has blundered
or at least has not taken the correct
path and allowed the white to stabilize
the position so this was the moment
Bishop takes E5 was a big move by Peter
because that's a big decision yeah you
take on E5 you know that this Pawn on F5
probably is going to fall and you have
to calculate everything very precisely
Knight to C3 now if you do take on F5
then I can just go Bishop to G4 and this
was the key in the position I have this
idea of Bishop to G4 you take on F2 I
take on D7 and I'm actually winning an
exchange you take on D7 I take on F2
still black has a lot of compensation
even in that position nevertheless that
was the Tactical shot that Peter had in
mind with this move Knight to C3 he did
not take on F5 he played Rook to d8 Rook
to H3 an author G6 if Peter goes G4
stabilizes the position if you do a take
on F5 I will take that and open up the G
file that's quite uh clear that white is
going to have a nice not necessarily
Advantage but initiative given by that
activity over the G file and Peter might
be playing the spoilers role in this one
how are we doing on time
yeah well he made the draw already uh
to oh he did not play G4 he played F6
F6 F6
that that sure landed a pawn in my midst
what if I just take that phone yeah
good idea
wait a second if you take the pond Queen
H4 is not working Rook up one that's the
only thing I can see right that's a big
thing
we cannot play Greenwich for the move
which you normally would like to play in
order to give as you were about to say
uh Rook F1 is a check and it's a
discovered attack on the queen you win
material and black is a happy camper so
in this position after Rook takes F6
Peter was obliged
and then what why we gave them he wants
to go Knight G3 and if he could please
please please
uh drop a night and capture the pawn on
e4 now black has a problem because
component C4 is hanging upon E4 is
hanging but the queen on D3
I might end up regretting that I was
forced to trade queens and one of the
bigger problems that black no idea of
has in this position is his time he only
has two minutes on his clock he made the
move really it wasn't updated on our
report maybe we can Bishop to D5 what
did he do I'm not sure no Bishop to B4
wait a minute okay we should go to C4
oh
that's a crafty move nice Bishop before
didn't expect it but what he's realizing
is that when you get this Knight G3
where she played and Knight takes E4 in
the position
white is going to be for choice so that
he played Bishop B4 in order to capture
this Knight
does he really want to do that I think
he wants to go Queen D3 He played Knight
to G3 while he was aiming at was that
after Queen to D3 if you played first
before white commits the Knight to G3
white can play the move Knight left you
got it and that's just going to be a
much better placement for tonight right
now after Knight to G3 maybe I can go
Queen to D3
uh Knight to G3 on the board and now
you're suggesting Queen to D3 and I
think he wants to play it
at least he was covering yes so let's
say Bishop C2 then we take Queen and
Bishop C3 this is the idea wait a minute
Kobe shop C2 can I take Queen takes C3
[Music]
yes
sweet
the Dutch have a wonderful word by the
way it's called the rossing
uh surprise because he takes it Queen
takes C3 in a harassing nice okay Queen
is really cool it's really pretty so I
guess you oh
encouraging Rook take C3 though I cannot
believe that maybe there was something
C4 guys Queen takes C4 and then Queen
takes C3
that's a check
don't tell me oh my gosh that's a check
Shack no no it's unbelievable we've
we've seen it in the blitz well if he
didn't see it again that they almost
made well right now the problem is he
touched the Rook on F and he's obliged
to move the road he needs to play rookie
6 or Rook F7 oh my gosh
oh my goodness so Queen came to C4 with
check oftentimes you would play a move
like Bishop to D5 but because he touched
his Rook he has to move it but I don't
know why he wanted to play Rook D6 I
guess he anticipated in esc3 exactly
and he thought that he would get the
triples
oh my word oh and now you see he's lost
a Tempo he did because his Bishop could
have been on D5 a moment before and oh
it rains it pours Bishop G4 and our
tournament leader is wobbling oh Shaq
was rattled by that situation absolutely
absolutely
this bishop to G4 which was lurking in
the back in the position for so many
moves exactly
and you remarkably Shaq played the move
Shaq was worried about Bishop B3 he
played Bishop D5 to protect his exchange
and he got hit on the other side of the
board with Bishop G4 Rook f8 shacked
down to his last 30 seconds but yeah
again seven minutes and probably a
winning position for Peter right now yes
now the question is
I would love to play a move like Queen
C7 you take my queen I'll take your rook
and the bad news don't end there for
chakra because firuja is about to win
his game against Levon aronia and do we
have Queen C7 on the board by the way
he's a seven he's on the board
but I wanted to correct myself and say
that after Queen takes C7 Bishop takes
E6 I am hanging my Rook on H3 but how is
that so I was going to play the move
Rook H4 is a Prelude to Queen C7 he
played it immediately yes I think white
is better in the end much better much
better that's why he played the move H5
okay but now we can just trade Queens
take the rook and move our Rook
I think what Shaq is dreaming is just
getting the Knight to C5 though ah good
point that's what I think he wants
getting the Knight to C5 and then to D3
but what white can do given that his up
material he can take on C5 and return
the exchange very nicely and then take
only four with the Knight and say okay I
mean I'm taking on C5
or maybe maybe the Rope
yes maybe The Rook yes yes yes
yeah if you take with the Knight
actually I think Bishop to G4 might be a
little bit problematic no no no you're
still doing good but uh definitely white
in the driver's seat and wow Ali Raza
did you say
are you kidding me are you telling me
that the golden boy is going to make a
triple crown he's going to be in pole
position to do so he he's winning this
one
so far away look at the same game yes
he's about to just push his pawns on the
queen side G5 G4 H5 H4
a lot seems like a lot right yes that's
a very good observation because one of
his problems at least according to his
critics was his end games yes but he's
been showing time and time again in the
last couple of weeks that his end games
have improved
definitely the young man has been
putting a lot of work into his
weaknesses and it shows time on the
clock is a factor though we've got five
minutes for Lavon who as you said is
losing foreign less than two yeah
um that was one of the things seriously
I I played on the same team as Magnus in
Holland
um we played for the hell there's some
chess club and Magnus was this young boy
and what was he doing he was winning
games in the end game
well the youths are supposed to be
sacrificing pieces and ponds and you
know scrambling no no Magnus was a great
and it was like he was almost born with
a kind of a feeling for the ending and
uh good end game play is the Hallmark of
world champions why I was not born like
that exactly exactly exactly that's so
hard Bad Karma you're being punished
trust me
G5 very powerful move
alireza is ready to play G4 H5
don't allow them over to D5 so if you go
G4 Rook to D5 might be a little bit
problematic what he takes on H2 I like
this move
greed
man's no ghost emotion
greedy's good read is good uh Rook to D5
and then just defend it it's important
not to play G4 yes
just in case if somebody so you can
start with Rook D7 right it's still
possible to lose any position
proving Time and Time Rook H7 I think
I'm just playing H6 yes and next turn G5
and wow those so what if I take on C7
well those are three connected past
pawns I understand that but I go G7 and
now look G5
yeah I would have I should have played
King H3 first actually King ah look at
very smart what level did he played now
before uh now be okay let me just
refresh I'm gonna refresh my board sorry
for that it says played you for please
[Laughter]
okay time to come back with the King
okay I still I'm not threatening but I'm
gonna go King H4 and then finally I will
be threatening G4 once I go King H4 G4
is over yes once I connect those pawns
and not get checkmated on the H5 yeah
this is this is not a race no the pawn
is already on F3 and its colleague is
going to show up on G3 this game is in
the back but I saw something that looked
crazy look at this game between Gary
Kasparov and Lanier Dominguez and tell
me this is a regular chess this just
looks like a reverse king's Indian
Queen's Indian that went wrong we're
gonna ask three seconds to make a move
no I think he left he just flagged yes
he just left a flag no at the moment
we'll move to this game there is a flag
yes okay and how
with a five second increment could you
flag this position because you can play
King B8 and yes and linear almost feels
like it's his story about it yeah no of
course I mean everybody has such a big
respect uh Gary yeah it doesn't feel
great the wind is on time no no no no no
like that and to be frank I mean White's
position is that from the still
dominated but guys let's go back to
firusha because it still hasn't closed
the show yet and if he does he still
hasn't closed the show oh
and Peter is winning Peter one one yes
Peter one not winning one and by the way
Rook D1 is a tricky move once again we
can show the obvious threat of mate G4
the desired G4 Rook H1 would be painful
and now H4 King H4 now that is
threatening the move G4 finally King H4
threatens G4 so he had to give a check
put the king in the way and well you
also have another problem right now as
white yes to E8 is coming that is the
big problem how are we going to answer
well he played B5 he's trying to create
his own password yes but you're so far
from creating anything on the queen side
exactly
Rook E8 or Rook d8 rook d8 and this
looks winning right now these look like
uh it's over over
set position yes and that's that's all
she wrote that is a because Rook E2
check is such a powerful move then you
can the passive white rook and then you
can go Rook to C2 get your Rook behind
the pawns and finally you will three
connected past bonds when they came so
that is a killer below rookie two if he
wins and makes the hat-trick in St Louis
that was just he'll walk away with three
hundred thousand dollars more than that
yeah more than that it is yeah 110. 310
probably not counting it correctly
exactly a tip a tip for the the good
staff at the uh at the uh chess club
staff will enjoy the tip
he's taking everybody to dinner after
this WOW yep yep yep yep no question
about it dinner on alireza
Rook E8 and you can see just look at
yeah it's not the best he knows this is
over yep you're not even close like it's
not even a race nope it's not
competitive at this point exactly by the
way uh once again Peter did win upending
our tournament leader and what's going
on between Hikaru and wow it's looking
really good two three four good so let's
drop Bobby wins he gets half a point
behind Ali Reza yes and very very nice
but look at this uh you don't usually
see a pawn structure like this but this
night on F6
covers it's like a magical Shield if you
will covering so many squares it's like
a spider yeah exactly if the Rook had
moved the B8 king would have
but that is very easy right you go H3 E4
Rook H1 H2 Knight on you don't have
Knight G4 and it's over we have a new
tournament leader The Golden Boy remains
golden
alireza jeez honestly yes
I don't want to say it's unprecedented
tournaments in a row okay but guys
finishing the game right now yeah the
bishop looks trapped Rook D2 followed by
H2 H2 but actually yeah where to put the
bishop I guess you have one check but
that doesn't really help you no Rook D2
just wins the game The Rook D2 just wins
the game I agree with that
Rook D2 expected
yeah
and I think we're going to probably see
a resignation okay
hopefully again the number of decisive
games is just astounding this would be
our fourth but look at this Peter he
will say I need just a couple of more
days and I will win this game I was
warming up
the start exactly H2
uh not my G4 yet because you still have
to worry about
um because it's a legal pip yeah King E5
uh something maybe to be said for Rook
E2 just to remind white that he may have
to drop back with his King yes he played
it and uh
you know as a second before again as the
president of the pond grubbers Club you
know
okay good to see the member oh King E5
uh
can you find that that was helpful but
now I have also Knight D5 ideas yes you
want to go B5 the problem is
right Knight D5 check and that Rook
cannot capture the Knight once it's gone
there Knight B5 check wins on the spot
yes uh the King has to go back and
Knight takes seats E3
and there's no way that Knight C4 check
oh Knight C4 now Knight C4 check yeah
or maybe D5 yeah okay resignation yes
I think in this final position that he
resigned D5 was would be uh the fake
fatal move because Knight C4 check and
Rook but never mind another crazy round
at penultimate round as we go to the
championship round and what did you see
in this round uh Christian that got you
excited I'm just seeing a young man that
wants uh to make the hat-trick in St
Louis that is firuja I mean with the
black piece is such a dominant display
he is not afraid to take points he's not
afraid he's not shying away from any
sort of tactical situations Knight takes
F4 I was saying don't play Knight takes
F4 it just looks bad it looks like
you're allowing white to gain so much
speed in his position he said no give me
the pawn right you definitely enjoy
seeing that yeah I know that I know you
saw Knight F4 uh gift me the pawn Let's
uh let's go discuss the details later
yeah let's go definitely a very
interesting uh game and as we are
entering the championship round he's the
favorite but I'm also seeing a very
motivated Fabiano caruana he won two in
a row yes right now who is he playing
against and look at this uh Anastasia
laid the table for around nine now final
round's parents final round Fabiano
carono plays against the Wesley so
aliens secular will meet with sikaru
Nakamura who just lost two games and
looking forward to to win at least
something right
plays against
both those players just got up ended
exactly will play against Peter Smith
[Music]
will play against linear Domingos my
goodness everything to play for in the
standings reveal that we have a soul
leader Anastasia exactly now because
usually yeah
but look at the chasing wolves only half
a point behind yes
all of them are looking forward and
perhaps everything will be decided in
the last round so restless so you know
what the problem for our lireza is but
none of these players Fabiano Yan and
chat we are playing against each other
right all of them have shots as
potentially catching up with Oliver
six and a half but once again alireza in
the last round is going to be playing at
sikaru right who you just told us went
down to his second successive defeat but
my goodness everything you played for
and yeah Wesley is out I rub it in
[Laughter]
yes it does and we're going to be taking
a very very short break as we come back
for our
ninth and final round
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
before
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to our
show let's check the standings before
the last round yes yes round eight this
is where you stand exactly
is on the first place six points and
only half a point behind we have Fabiano
caruana
they're hoping of course to win their
games absolutely today Wesley saw has
four and a half points then Leon
aronians three and a half like and
Hikaru Nakamura has the same three and a
half points Petersfield there's three
points linear Dominguez 3 and Gary
kasparo is in the last position
bad tournament another pairings for this
the championship round Anastasia and
very very important bearings Fabiano
Carana plays against the Wesley soap
alireza will face Hikaru Nakamura can he
make it a Triple Crown
is placed versus linear Domingos and the
players are in the player in how busily
scrambling their way with a new position
and there you see nepo on the left and
chakriar only two of them yes at the
moment and let's Shuffle up our pieces
on the back Rank and see about this new
position
Anastasia Shuffle let's do them yes 85
dishes only 85 I mean of course it's in
the list right it's less than 100.
number 85.85 yes well the queen side
looks okay Christian but uh break down
this position for us the king side is
going to be a bit problematic with those
two Bishops right right because they
were will be vying for position how are
you going to set up your Pawn structure
you probably will play G3 and F4 right
so you're not going to Castle most
likely on the king side
um I'm expecting G3 F4 open up the
bishops get the knight from B1 up to C3
play the move d4 Queen to D2 get the
room from A1 to D1 by long castleing and
then I'm not 100 sure what to do with
the Knights what about Bishop David yeah
that's a good question yes the bishop
spongy one might suffer a little bit
momentarily right so it's it's a tricky
one I have to say but I can see some
potential to be leading towards a very
um chest look like position
what do you think about the grab opening
the grab opening and chest begins with
one G2 G4 is this one of the moves that
you find attractive uh Christian I I do
yeah I like you for why not I also like
it and also like the fact that you open
the bishop because B7 Pawn can be a
problematic sometimes right if you put
some pressure on this Pawn maybe C3
Queen B3 later I don't know is just an
idea but sure but Bishop on G8
no real Pawn weaknesses just the pawns
on B7 C7 E7 uh only protected once uh oh
pardon me uh apologies for that the
Knight on E8 also uh protects C7 boy did
I get that it's easy to hold only this
pawn and B7 and E7 are the wikis I don't
see any quick checkmates and if you
think about it uh you're so much closer
from castling kingside queenside excuse
me yeah as white for example and as
black of course as well so it makes some
sense to gain as much space as possible
on the king side not worry about let's
say a potential weakness of the king
because you're not castling on that side
right so G4 to me to my eyes it makes a
lot of sense and I think actually G4 G6
F4 or F5 I mean it already feels like
white is having a very nice Advantage I
would respond to G4 with G5 myself G4 G5
G5
whoa whoa whoa whoa that's how I would
tackle this position okay
um something about H4 of course of
course sacrifice
this would be the this looks like a
harmonious Pawn sacrifice
in this broadcast
and we should have but we haven't named
the openings
we have a free hand guys nobody named
the openings we should be naming them
yes
this could be the Sarah one the
carlovish Gambit I mean I'll name it
however you want and it's gonna stick I
was about to say you know we're
recognizing uh the three of ourselves uh
the Sarah one attack sure yes
here it sounds it sounds good
good
but more importantly look what we did oh
my gosh I was influenced he played
Christian played the Jedi mind trick on
me
um
congratulations but you I'm sorry you
you've got you've got a serious chance
here shame on you guys for not choosing
uh the Triple Crown winner nobody choose
actually but I still hope our father who
can make it exactly and I don't think
you will mind if Fabiano Carana will win
the store number it wouldn't be it
wouldn't be a tragedy no not at all I
you know I did something very silly I
didn't pick alireza because I was just
playing the mathematical odds he just
won two of the strongest tournaments
in the world of all time played here the
rapid and Blitz the sinful cup I thought
he was going to let down like he was
just going to say
enough enough is enough and just you you
can't help it it's human nature to relax
yes after just completing a marathon and
look what it's a sad situation for Peter
because Peter has been analyzing with
Gary but finally they meet and they play
against each other play against each
other they cannot analyze with each
other anymore this is it they have to
face each other right now
okay okay Wesley said do you mind I
would love to uh he was waiting for this
moment he was waiting for his game
against Peter Exactly learning maybe to
spend some time on the lighting together
with Gary it doesn't matter how many
points Gary has he's great player I mean
he just I mean even clocks are ticking
it's another story but if you just have
chance to analyze with him I mean it's
it's a treasure fantastic well I mean at
the ultimate moves I mean it's the trash
talking you know happy get-together that
the players have each and every year and
there's Gary on John's team and he's
competitive oh we should have played
and he's like the critical of the
players as they stand up why did you
play F5 on your last move and not F6
don't you remember Rex is coming into
the game you should make it easier on
him
he's like dude man
I was just thinking of a good kibbits no
no mercy not the position but he never
he is a competitor Christian absolutely
he still is a competitor and now he
wants to beat Peter actually
yes but Peter is warming up right he won
uh the last game of day two he started
off with a draw a sharp draw against
firusha and then he won a critical game
against muhammadi arov and my media are
over let's be honest I mean he was
dominating the event up to that point
right
but
I'm actually wondering how the position
was if muhammadi Arab wouldn't have
touched his rook and almost oh my God
poor Mommy then and this is through the
magic of Television we just saw this
move Queen takes C4 check check to
Black's King and there The Rook
what what and look how she shaking the
King right now yeah you can see it on
his hands he's like oh my goodness what
did I do yeah so let's actually remind
our viewers what happened a couple of
times before yes in one game he missed
two League he played two illegal moves
in the rapid and Blitz that came earlier
before the sigil cut yeah exactly and
the last game of the same tournament he
played this move Rook just he has to
remember it and just he thought it's
check against the Jeffrey song and it
turned out to be no chick and Jeffrey
just took his bishop and he lost the
game he just resigned next move so some
strange things are happening with Shaq
even though still he showed really great
chess in this event absolutely uh by the
way we've just saw one interesting idea
that these two players have been looking
at it went d2d4 which is as we know a
move that we like in regular chess
either E4 or D4 grabbing the center
perfectly perfectly sensible and then I
saw a G5 and uh and uh NEPA side of the
temple he said you know if you're going
to play G5 this bishop needs a roll let
me play H4
and then came G takes H4 Knight F3 E6
and nepo stopped and he said I don't
like it
uh-huh I don't like it uh because it's a
little bit uh it's not that easy well
but it's not that easy to win back the
pawn you know and even though yes you
you just played the position normally uh
he didn't like it so he didn't like it
because there's that Bishop on H1 yep
and then if you do go G3 then I'm going
to be able to exchange the pawn on H4
for the pawn on G3 and actually be a
pawn pawn up right right so if that
Bishop would be on F1 and The Rook would
be on H1 that would be a completely
different story exactly then you'd have
the natural pressure down the uh H file
but yeah it's just interesting to see
the players play around with the
position a bit did you pick up anything
from the the pre-game warm-up analysis
Christian no uh actually not as much
obviously there's still some tension
there uh definitely mamadiaro was a bit
disappointed you can see it on his face
he was disappointed because and I I did
look at the position after Queen to C4
if you do go Bishop to D5 the computer
is saying 0 0. the position seems to be
more or less balanced nevertheless if
you look deeper at it it does feel like
black has a very nice initiative on the
f file for example if you do take on E5
now you're already lost I'm going to go
Queen to F7 triple down the f file
threaten to give a checkmate with Rook
to F1 you have to attend that threat
Bishop to E2 but now I have ideas of
Knight to D7 Knight to C5 fast or even
move such as Bishop to B3 as wow the
computer is recommending so definitely
an Intrigue and by the way Bishop to B3
has a very nice thread Rook to C6 is a
threat for example if you play something
like
six boom surprise yes
but with the bishop on B3 I'm
controlling your Escape score on D1 so
Queen to F2 comes with the Checkmate a
very very nice position unfortunately
after Queen C4 you touch the Rook you
have to put it on E6 or F7 and in both
situations you're going to be much much
worse after Queen takes C3 already
borderline winning position for white
not only that but it felt like after
Bishop to D5 he forgot about Bishop to
G4 right and that was all she wrote so
an unfortunate event for chakra but
still he has chances to catch up with
the leader right now alireza
one more quick look at the current
standings going into the championship
round Anastasia can I boldly State the
obvious yeah I mean my
sister winning the tournament and that's
it no discussions anymore but if he
makes a draw you you stole
you stole my notes if he makes a draw
there's a potential for not just a
playoff of two players but a playoff of
four players the only undefeated player
in the tournament a draw and the he
opens up the door for playoffs and who's
going to win it only time will tell you
know we waited three days to hear you
say hey but it was worth the wait it was
worth the wait it was tagged like
um Anastasia uh predictions for uh our
Championship rounder all I'm going to
ask you is are we going to see a playoff
yeah that's
[Laughter]
Anastasia only time we talk yes
last time when I tried to predict
something was London candidates 2013 yes
this is the final round I'm sure you
predicted both losers
leaders would lose impossible ways but
not this one exactly exactly and there
you see the handshake and they are off
looks like E4 is again that's actually a
surprising
the turtle's so funny it sounds right
because it was like the one move that we
really I was looking at D4 looking at G4
it just feels like you want to open up
the Bishops for whatever reason right
right but alireza says E4 is a good move
just great game Space maybe he's
thinking F5 E5 G5 all right all right
let's tangle now we go game guys now we
have an imbalance game
the place for wind as we came on
broadcast we talked about the fact that
Hikaru is a streaky player and he's on a
losing streak unfortunately for him he's
not happy about that nepo is also one of
those players if things go wrong they
can go very very wrong now
this is a very competitive situation
hikar is playing the Next Generation you
know he's thinking like okay I've got to
school him now uh and tell him right I
mean you School the young kid that you
allow one of your peers to potentially
take the championship and then you put
up a nice YouTube video that's going to
make a lot of numbers
we should call it something like that I
don't know if in this position okay I
was about to say the nice thing about G5
seriously it's not a joke I can control
F4 why do I find that compelling because
I'm thinking about the move Knight C6
not so easy for you to defend
conveniently the pawn on D4 so you're
going to advance the pawn on D5 and
Shazam I have an outpost no playing uh
an alacrine yeah something
a queen side
or F5 it's interesting because E4
actually was played in the Nepal game as
well and uh he responded with F5
directly
not g5s F5 directors
and I think he's playing a Muhammad Yaro
here I'm not mistake there it is no yes
it's uh that's a shack one Shaq played
E4 never played it with the white F5
takes wow okay interesting
with the white pieces the same yes we we
have two games that are are identical to
one another I think they're also
checking yeah position for uh
was it
Shack and nipple analyzing together I
think so uh
yes
look at this if we see G4
uh there was of course the very famous
uh
Gothenburg variation where the Argentine
players had come to the candidates with
a variation of the night orphan mine
guess what and they've sprang their
Innovation against the Soviet players
okay uh cares and and everybody saw that
Geller
had the same position so the Soviet
players all stopped and they waited for
Geller
and then maybe
what he showed it was great
I'm sorry Christian I interrupted you
we're about to say guess what no guess
what the future game is very similar
tough one and I'm not sure do we see G4
is on the board
yes
uh Christian do you know what the move
Rook A5 threatens yes
he's going to be tasered after this uh
broadcast what what it threatens my
goodness Rook A5 you're right this is a
chess 960 position it's so crazy I mean
it's sicaragu just what what is he doing
what is this I'm married he is probably
very lucky he's not losing immediately
after like a move like Queen D2 hitting
some things
no I don't like this move at all uh
other players probably just drop back to
f8 with the Rook Christian yes yes well
I mean mommy they are oh my goodness in
my media arrows game no so let's move to
that one let's move to that one
the same position The Rook came to A5 I
wonder if these guys actually do look at
one another I'm sure because Queen takes
G5 Bishop takes D4 that's hilarious well
you know they have the digital screens
yes so they can actually see all the
games also of course they don't have to
move around they have the digital
screens with all the positions so as I'm
looking at the Players right now
Christian does it mean that the the
frames to their right are you have to
wait normally you have to stand up and
go there yes but some players might
might still can see this they might be
able to yes might be able to check from
wow okay we do have some
b2b3 there's only one move
take that night on B1 take it as fast as
possible don't you believe in the Fisher
Gambit
I guess you can consider A5 no
no don't why not
I'll go Knight C3 and I have four yeah
I'll happily take your Bishop all right
they're gonna be I and you take back
yeah yeah I mean okay this is crazy
Bishop takes B1 but
I was thinking about it Lavone is
thinking about it
I got it a bit later but okay yeah
trapping your bishop and he did take uh
let me go again to our tournament leader
and by the way after the move Rook to A5
not believing his Good Fortune Ali Reza
just played tonight
three Knight C6 Knight C3 and we have
caught up to the players I don't know
Anastasia but this it's like they try to
play normally like nights yesterday
Knight F3 but then you just have a rook
when they fight that's the only problem
the rest is okay
you just develop your nice night F6
fortnights developed well the one thing
is
this bishop on G1 you never got to play
F4
uh is this one starting to look good for
black
what is our D6 let's just develop right
96 right why not Knight D6 Queen f8 and
then blonde Castle
right it seems like I have all my pieces
playing a role and for what it's worth
this Rook is not being tickled you
cannot tickle it anymore and that cannot
became anymore because I take only two
you know I think this has worked out
brilliantly absolutely for black I was
actually black is saying okay you can
try to get rid of my Rook play A3 before
but then where you will Castle your king
and what you will do with your king you
pushed all your pawns that's one thing
but it's not even so easy to threaten
anything before but I hear what you're
saying you know but what Christian is
saying is give me the chance to play
Queen f8 I'll pass along
and I'll start to break up the center
and Bishop will come to C4
wow I know I mean I think Ali raise it
it looks beautiful losing already it's
so bad it's a difficult position for Ali
Reza right right
and by the way the times are very hard
to read 16 minutes uh for Hikaru 16
minutes and 40 seconds and 60 minutes
that's not a factor yet let's just go
around the board and let's jump to well
we're seeing something familiar with
between
um Ian and Lanier let's not forget
Lanier is the defending champion in our
Showdown
and well once more black seems to but he
didn't go with the Rook yeah it didn't
go to the Republican but uh black seems
to be doing pretty good here uh whoops
excuse me this is the shack rear game
I also wonder what Fabi is doing like
yes however how is it going with Fabi is
within Striking Distance so we
definitely have yes we have to check
okay okay they played they played one of
our lines G4 G4 G6 and F4 and Fabi was
not at the board so perhaps he was doing
exactly what we were discussing checking
the other games see if he can spot any
patterns right by the way I like this uh
Queen A4 a you're leading with the pawn
in front of your uh Queen I have seen
this in Old Indian positions when I'm
black oftentimes my knight is on D7 I
will have A5 A4 Queen A5 Bishop to D5
was played a exchange on D5 and Knight
to C2 okay covering is actually once
again so my history Maybe
um for the moment I'm not completely
satisfied with the role that this bishop
is playing here
and it feels a little bit sacrifice it
if you don't like anything I'm very very
as a commentator I'm very happy to
sacrifice their their material yes is
there anything to be said about Bishop
takes C3
I don't know we can play before maybe
later
Bishop takes C3 I mean I am taking three
points that is wow
and then I think G1 as well so my knight
is not getting trapped and you've kind
of messed up the king a lot right right
so more or less at the end of the day
um
three pawns for a night
not it's it's not easy to assess the
position not at all because maybe G8 is
protected and it's not so easy to
challenge the open file you might prefer
White and the Knights are protecting the
king quite well yes well and actually it
could turn into an attack against the
black king after A6 but it was a nice
try
[Laughter]
in years of broadcasting together I
don't think I ever ever tried I ever
stated back for a Christian I mean he's
been waiting I don't know how many years
but never said nice try
to try yes okay
three days and look already you know
first bullying us about the prophecy
wow wow uh I wanted to go back to our
tournament leader because when we left
it guys I gotta tell you this this look
ugly
ugly for alireza we're looking at Queen
f8
simple idea we want a castle we want to
drop our Queen to F4 we want to drop our
Bishop to uh
C4 where we get a very very fast
initiative and we haven't sacrificed
anything The Rook looks misplaced until
you say how to take advantage of The
Rook you can't find a way to do that
then suddenly The Rook is looking pretty
good it protects G5 it patrols the fifth
ring hits A2
well I mean I would rather have it on F4
but you can't have everything we think
uh well we understand the move H3 right
Anastasia we're gonna on a good day put
our Bishop on H2 and uh pretend that uh
it's it's a monster but it's not doing
anything on H2 again Queen f8 let's just
play a few moves around with it for a
moment none of this will happen guys E5
was played E5 E5 that's a very
aggressive move oh yes he's in a very
aggressive mood it seems like it yes E5
okay
what if I take it just I always try to
check the captures okay yeah absolutely
that's it so I always said the first
thing you always check whenever you're
calculating A variation the first thing
is checks is there a check in the
position even if it's the stupidest
check in the world you have to look at
it second is a capture so what how would
you like to continue
[Laughter]
after we have done it I'm not sure like
what's going on again Bishop will just
be a great feeling great exactly you
know I thought you point of three but
the the trade uh improves the mood of
blacks pieces so we don't like it yes so
baby
first I liked how you put it yesterday
you said let's exchange pieces on my
terms exactly and I like actually that's
interesting it sounds really good I I
always thought of these trades as you go
to a Marketplace and you have a currency
say you have bread you have eggs you
have milk and you start to trade with
the market yes and then you want to do
it on your terms so in this position if
I'm black I really don't want to take
the night and improve the queen for
example
and white really doesn't want to see
that Bishop dominate the bishop on G1
over to you uh Christian D takes if I
was pleased he takes E5 on the board so
we don't need to check our conversations
Knight takes E5 we expect Knight takes
E5 to come quite quickly I don't think
there is I mean you can go Knight C4 but
I don't think it makes any sense just
take the pawn back exactly and the
assessment of this position
we think the objective assessment yes at
least according to the engines and we
trust the engines in general not only um
is that black is actually doing quite
well minus 1.2 so that's pretty
significant that's significant
significantly queen of Fate was probably
a bit better but E5 is also a very
aggressive move and I think one that
does the job you know why I much much
preferred Queen f8 is because ice felt
that the pawn on D4 was more vulnerable
than the pawn on E7 so on a good day I
could threaten to play Knight takes and
queen check I understand
hikaru's uh thought process D4 right now
what he's going to do most likely is
going to go Queen to F6 and he's going
to activate the queen on the file but on
a more active Square creating the
battery on the long diagonal that could
potentially become deadly okay so I feel
like this is why he played E5 and
decided to go this path right as opposed
to putting a screen on f8 Queen on F6
might even be
everything right now Knight to D4 no
trades for you now we're expecting Queen
to F6
high expectations definitely now you
also help your king to get
sold yes
okay and that would very much fall into
play with what you suggested let's just
take a look at the pretenders to the
throne what's happening between Shaq and
Lavon things are a little crazy here as
well
um
white Rook
somehow
a year ago
and uh me thinks that the white Rook is
more active than the Black Road
well not only that how do you like that
is that is that the kind of commentary
to just say anything against this
statement yes
but are you soaring with this oppressive
poetry yes sir we need to check this out
check what he's doing right now oh
because he's creating some immediate
threats
alert alert A5 King to B7 unfortunately
you cannot do that because the pawn on
D7 right not allow me to pick that one
up if you try to go A5 okay the question
is are you in time or will I be able to
just simply go on ID3
I want to go to C5
but I think I might want to take on D7
yes and then C5 and then it could be
amazing box yeah yes and this tribe will
really work guys I suspect it really
will uh the other thing is I don't want
to jump on the bad qualities of Black's
position but with the queen on H4 it
almost feels like you're inducing me to
want to activate my Bishop with Bishop
to G3 even if you take the pawn on H2 uh
the bishop will end up on G3 with the
tempo but I like what you said uh
especially Christian Rook takes D7 and
Knight C5 might be a Checkmate Knight to
D3
in case of a7a5 Knight to D3 looks great
let's show those type of situations yeah
on the board let's go A4 right right say
black is trying to create his own
country exactly and based on this bishop
and let's just do it let's just have
some fun at the Players expense Knight
C5 we can show one quick Checkmate one
two two if you go there I go 97 yeah if
you go to d8 I can go let's give the
Checkmate
oh you have to show style uh so you're
gonna you're gonna run away You're Gonna
attempt to run away
and I will take this and I will take
this and it will be terrible so you have
to go here but then I take only six with
with a queen and I have to go between
Queen are you struggling already
sweet that's a problem guys that's a
huge problem by the way Queen G5
inviting the check a very dangerous
check but he's saying okay you can give
a check but you're not going to have a
strong follow-up after that is that true
though that's uh that that's well I'm
pretty sure he's going to run to d8 I
think so too there's no way let me put
the move Queen uh G5 on the board
so he does want to chase our Rook out of
F7
okay shall we just have a quick look see
okay
first we have Windows 7 Network series
Rook C8 can we do any well we need we
need more fire right but this is the
problem I suppose yes uh I don't see any
kind of checkmates well just a moment I
mean it's it is frightening isn't it it
is yes
yes
we've got
what beautiful I know I know I know I
know but we're still not convincing
though I mean why not
um and then King seven
this is where our Bishop needed to be on
H4 so that we would have Brilliance
um Queen A6 is seductive uh Christian
but I didn't see a winner there's not
the clear follow-up though I've never
been to D6 so it's not uh winning Knight
2 F3 seemed to be a very very intriguing
option right now because after Queen G6
Queen G6
probably Rook 37
um
oh
nothing but boy you've got to calculate
this too now now you're done now it's
done now
so Bishop F6 I will have to take that
and now our work is kind of
deeply entrenched right it is
Bishop C5
what did you say no no I just mean that
of course the whole idea is to keep the
Rook somehow yes
no matter what you want to keep it in
the danger zone you have to move this
Rook okay probably white will lose the
most of Advantage here so this is a but
still a very complex position guys this
is not easy I have to you know pay
homage to my colleague Gary Kasparov
come on Gary get on the tournament book
scoreboard
so Peter and he can check this video
after still
and this is what we've got well
it looks again it's not the fact that
Gary doesn't get good positions he does
he gets good positions uh with Advantage
like he had against Fabi uh it's just
that he's at times he's losing uh on on
time we saw this but he's always behind
on time what is the current clock at
times
let's check what's Gary has seven
minutes and 35 seconds against 11
minutes okay so he's behind on time to
Peter unfortunately that game's not
crucial for our standings we'll go to
the Fabiano game for a moment again I
mentioned that when we left it I didn't
like this bishop on G1 neither did Fabby
he's trying to bring it back to life
and
Wesley the Wesley looks good I but
there's no reason I mean your Pawn is on
A5 but
once it gets to A6 if it doesn't do
damage
guys I think it's all about the alireza
game right now
it's it's also getting explosive so
let's check let's go let's go we should
definitely take a look because that B3
move I mean if it was clean on me fine
those dark squares around the king
they're so cool whoa whoa what the first
thing Hikaru is looking at right now is
Queen E7 Queen F6 trying to take
advantage of the dark source as soon as
possible but then you will change your
Queens
but if it's not winning I I don't think
I would allow you to take that Knight on
T4 I think Queen F6 F4 might be an
interesting idea no you have to do it I
think you have to do it for your your
Bishop must protect this uh Knight but
you know he's looking for some
checkmates okay of course seven let's go
Queen E7 guys
let's try to get way through
uh so if we take the Knight just Knight
C4
so now the only way to stop me from
doing that is A4 right
A4
A4 Queen B4 I'm worried about Queen
before
close to your king and
uh
that might be arriving with devastating
concerts
so let's imagine that B3 in fact carries
no weight it just it's not a threat to
take the Knight we have a free hand to
do just about anything we want now what
would really
be nice is if we could play Queen A5
Queen A5 yeah that's uh something crazy
you know he's looking at ideas like that
and this is Hikaru Nakamura his he's a
creative genius
yes to replace this hook with the queen
yeah
[Laughter]
a queen f8 f8 yes excuse me he played
Queen effect I was thinking about this
move but it's a different ideas same
ideas what you said Christian go back
just for one second don't take on effort
didn't you have Knight E4 was Knight E4
move night in this moment after B three
or four no no no queen of Fate queen of
Fate yes which was played and
immediately I think took on F4 but what
if I go Knight E4 so F4 oh and then
let's say he thinks about Knight E4
and I'm just seeing checkmates after
Queen A3 and Queen A3 King B1 Queen B2
mate I guess Knight B1 maybe something
like that or not yes Knight B1 wow how
did he resist not playing Knight E4 if
you could provoke Knight B1
um not only that he didn't play it he
blitzed out G takes F4 right and that's
anticipated because because he he's
basically saying do me a favor
play B3 take C4 open up this diagonal
for my queen and that will be
devastating
actually you know why he played queen of
faith not Queen E7 to be able actually
to take on the four years now the Drew
cannot recapture yes but um so that's
why maybe he automatically took this
Pawn yes that wasn't so intent right as
you said the main idea is just to take
it immediately with the phone now cannot
recapture admire that I do I do really I
do and uh again I'm seeing our
tournament leader
uh the crown is slipping away Christian
uh this position
was played
what a queen of three
Queen F3 hoping to return the favor
against the B7 Square so that is getting
back into this game no yes no
Knight E5 okay what if I take the pawn
queen takes F4 though
yes so that's a question what if I take
the poem maybe then castling after he's
just a long Castle really you want to
play this I I'm not sure but like I
tried to understand what's the idea
maybe it's just better the ending or
what but why not long Castle
is Hikaru forgetting about the fact that
he cannot Castle
no no so in 95 Queen takes a four Queen
takes F4 Rook takes F4 ah and instead of
Knight to G6 long Castle
keep the knight in the center right yes
you yeah I I thought long castles was
automatic I'm also equally surprised
that Hikaru
um dropped back with his Knight out of
the center he does it with Tempo so he
doesn't lose time but I feel black has
led his Advantage slip suddenly
it looks symmetrical more symmetrical
and without Queens you cannot really you
take advantage of those dark squares
Queens I wanted Queens on the board I I
Hikaru wanted Queens on the body car I'm
not going to explain to hicaro that he
should have kept Queens on the board he
knows that already but okay after
castles
I feel whites
I mean white is fully back in the game
right I can Castle as well
you you wanted me to play King B2 I was
thinking the same also possibly yeah
okay
no no cause no castling H5 what
H5
yes because the Rook on A5 protects
it's too deep
very good I understand
you don't normally protect the party
like this but good eye it will
completely about it well spotted that's
why he played this move now I understood
the idea was to play Truth creating a
weakness that you can later one day
capture
finally we've got the idea and perhaps
we can look at the bird's eye view
because we're actually falling behind on
the moves they're not transmitting us as
well H5 was played something was played
by White Castle's Castle
yeah or hgs along and also castles Lots
you know sometimes when your your
opponent castles long it reminds you
that you can do it as well I mean thank
you I mean right hey I forgot about it
but I forgot about it I mean thank you
for reminding me right okay now that
we've created a weakness can we attack
it I don't know
Rook G5 95.
well you know what they say yes sir what
ah
[Laughter]
all right
I have petitioned let me tell you I have
petitioned okay so I really don't like
the fact that eurokon A5 is kind of
hindering the movement of my knight on
C3 so I would like to go A4
A4 why not take some more space
threaten maybe Knight B5 and just free
up the movement of my knight on C3
okay one story
on A5 Maybe
right and by the way just to give you
guys an update yeah it seems like one of
uh the Chasers chocolate Arman by the
arrow is in trouble against Levon aronia
okay because Shaq came into this
Championship round trailing oh he raised
it by a half a point hoping that uh
Nakamura could inflict some damage on
the tournament leader and then he could
catch up
and apple also
racing towards a draw right now oh
actually that one for sure is going to
be a draw there is no other then
possible result then nepo has got to
hope that not coming it almost feels
like firuja might actually have rods the
windy event in this position
unless
unless Fabiano against Wesley and the
position is still complex in that one
unless Fabiano wins that then it seems
like firuja with a draw might clinched
title but that's my prediction by the
way that they play in the final
breaks nice nice uh and it's a very yeah
thank you Christian and that is a very
complex position that's going on with
fabi's Bishop versus knight the eternal
battle which minor piece is better and
times are so close so even right I I
know that in Blitz night is better I'm
not sure about the Fisher random What's
Happening Here No It's Tricky nights but
the thing is that pawn majority on the
king side for White and the ideas of
Rook H4 Rook H6 it feels like white is
very depressing in the position right
maybe why does the one actually pressing
Rook G1 okay that's a surprise for me I
thought I I thought Fabi wasn't going to
try to bully this Pawn with Rook F1
maybe drop the bishop back play H4 and
go after the pawn with everything he has
okay and by the way guys shakuria is
back in the game what is not worse
anymore he's much worse on the clock
though only two minutes for shakuria are
against seven minutes that one is going
to be explosive for sure oh his Rook got
kicked out of the seventh rank
yes and this was the game where we were
anticipate Knight D3 Knight C5 yeah but
it was hard to find yes I mean somehow
the Knight got to A4 and why is Shaq
back one two three four
and he's upon now yes he's a pawn down
but oh and uh Lavon has offered a draw
with a repetition of moves Knight C5
Knight B7 Knight A4 was played almost
without hesitation Shaq is not going to
take it he knows that he needs to win
well he knows that he needs help
from Nakamura he's not going to take it
and by the way
nepo is in
what who has drawn his game so right now
he's praying through the gods yes
Ali Reza right for him to have a chance
and they're going to repeat yes yes I am
willing to make a draw chakra said I'm
willing to make a draw
and by the way after the trade he's
checking the results look at him yeah I
can he actually it's nice to know what
what actually you need to do exactly
your opponents the rivals they made
draws now maybe you can also do that
exactly he didn't play A4 the movie
suggested Bishop F3 was the choice of
ferrugia now Nakamura said I'm gonna go
back with the Knight to uh E5 I came
from that square a moment ago hitting
the bishop
well I probably want to keep the bishop
as white Bishop E2
no but but then maybe Knight will jump
on a five later on
like Bishop B2 and actually White
and I see how he raiser looking back at
the screens behind him to see the
results of his competitors as Rivals
position and to take a look at fabi's
position he knows
uh what he needs to do which is
basically a result because a draw might
just win him clinch in this position
especially in this end game uh having
drawds is massive
yes it is no so actually draw guarantees
him that I break for sure at least yes
at least at least yes
and Fabiano is not clear whether he's
better or not I don't think he's better
okay definitely some chances in that one
but he's not better objectively this is
uh this is the game for the tournament
and perhaps just perhaps the Triple
Crown something we've never witnessed I
mean it's not just extraordinary it's
unprecedented I mean in the in Gary's
career he's won three tournaments in a
row and probably many more as has
Anatoly karpov as world champion as has
Magnus but watching this 19 year old
steamroll a field
of elite Grandmasters is
amazing and to do it
this way this way yeah with three three
back to back to back to back I remember
Magnus you know winning a rapid world
championship and Blitz Championship one
after the other in Dubai in 2014. it was
very very impressive as well so yes I
mean just watching that unfold in front
of you you're going oh my God this was
so good
uh a2a4 by the way uh finally it would
appear that The Rook is suddenly and
surprisingly or maybe not surprisingly
vulnerable to uh getting trapped and to
give you an update position is starting
to look promising who's position
Fabiano's position so if if Fabiano
actually wins
then Ali Raza needs to win in order to
clinch
if he draws they go into a tie breaks
which is what Anastasia has been saying
guys yes if I win this one sorry I mean
I don't know what we have to do we have
to do something by the way there's a
terrible ugly ugly ugly trap that Hikaru
just said
um Rook C5 Knight B5 give me The Rook
Knight takes I want to take the Rook no
you don't night takes and oops and if
you recapture the Knight that last move
Bishop H7 served to purpose
wow big moments right now
how are you going to continue with the
white pieces exactly I cannot go Knight
DB5 can you go Knight cb5 Knight C B5
and get that Knight out of Dodge then
Bishop takes visually such a difficult
move to me right specifically for that
reason
yes
either the pawn or the night and I can't
make
I don't think that works because when
you take on D4 I take back with a rook
and I make some space for my king
because it's sweet
[Music]
okay
that is uh that's a nice point that you
don't have to walk into a discovery and
he places
my goodness look at those he's fighting
for what he's fighting for too I I mean
uh
it's not I mean he just plays all of
these difficult different positions he's
a very good attacker and he's a very
good Defender he's a very good tactician
he calculates well and his end games are
excellent I mean what else can you say
he's uh he's a universal player
Christian is and he's only 19 years of
age this is the scary part it's going to
get better he's only going to get better
he has like more than a decade to reach
his Peak maybe even maybe even more yes
remember it's scary different examples
yeah
so what to do what to do what about
fabric maybe
um
hey wait the pawn is on on G6 this is a
good sign for Fabby fans exactly we
should definitely stick with this one
for them wow that pawn on whoa
oh come on how can this not be winning
for white it looks good it looks good
but the honor is putting some pressure
on alireza so but what if Ali Reza wins
this guys he wins the tournament yes
that's it yes nothing else to discuss my
predictions will not work that's it
normally this is the way how it goes so
yesterday I had dinner with Fabiana I
told him after a pretty difficult day
too that he needs two and a half out of
three to potentially win the tournament
right it seems like even with three out
of three he's not going to win right
yeah I remember it was incredible he was
tied for first in the U.S Championship
with three rounds to go was Fabi he went
two and a half out of three in the final
three rounds and he was clear second
because one Sam Shanklin went three out
of three and won the tournament and uh
it was great of it for Sam remember yeah
I was not here but it was
yeah with this move Knight B5 it looks
like alireza has solved all of his
issues and
no I I don't see anything for nothing is
working yeah I don't see any advantage
anymore it looks to me like
foreign might be getting his first
Victory no against Peter good for him I
don't want to leave this game
right now it does feel like uh
we were about to see the tournament
decided right
in the next little while here Rook H1
wait I mean but now I can take on F5 and
Knight D3 and at least transition into
an opposite color Bishop yes you can
take on a five and land District what
about time it's 30 seconds only yes
but he's just he's just shaking his head
and saying
I don't want to make that Bishops of
opposite color position
finally it took him
nine rounds to do it but Gary is on the
scoreboard with a draw uh not been his
tournament he's played and Fabiano is
winning his game guys yes we have it
we are having a playoff oh boy oh boy
unless a miracle happens in this one or
in Fabiano's game who is completely
winning
wow no he cannot lose this one I mean
who what yeah no no
it's too symmetrical too simple too
simple
and
Karu kind of looking scans
like okay dinner time
nothing's happening
takes I think I'm taking with the people
I have D5 here
Maybe
maybe not
just don't want to uh
Leave myself with an isolated a pawn I
think I would probably put the pawn on
A5 just to ensure that I have a bishop
C3
uh when I need it
King C7
and the reason I think we'll play for
victories this position
my game is over uh King D6 no surprising
he went King it kind of with King D6 you
can be cheeky you can go to E5 or C5 I
mean if you place his Rook on H7 comes
King to just brings his King to G6 for
example if it's possible of course yeah
guys we're going to see a resignation in
the other one I think so I think we
should make an executive decision I'll
switch to the Fabi game because as you
say resignation may be imminent
we've got Rook A6 okay
King F7 Brook f8 oops oops okay right f8
he did not see it what no okay maybe
what still winning but Rook A8 was just
game over yes he is missed he is missed
Rook f8 crazy I don't know how it's
still completely winning yeah
Maybe
uh
uh no these types of players they you
put them away you don't let them hang
around they'll find some tricky tricky
way of saving a completely lost position
H7 and Rook h8 on tap for white Wesley
knows it's game over
he's going to have to take on f8 and
play an exchange down
because how do you give the exchange
though I mean Rook f8 right now and just
say okay I'm busted actually if people
are yes because everybody has to do it
H5 what age five
and then he'll take one to seven
probably I know
just
all the cases no H5 is a very strange
mobile I can definitely take that
this time effects
how much do you want to tell us
worry details by letter
I'm sure it's it's interesting wow why
didn't Bobby Bobby makes confounding
moves we don't understand
Bishop is on E5 suddenly and why is the
bishop on E5 why isn't the Rook on h8
already I have no idea I can just expect
why would you leave the pawn on H5 it
makes no sense what
oh oh there goes the night he blundered
the night Rook takes G7 okay maybe he
was losing anyway but still this is a
knight this is come on yeah you take the
Knight yeah
that H Pawn is not going anywhere with
the bishop patrolling the H2 Square
Bishop E5 and Rook F6 plays itself yes
of course I'm a position Bobby's done
his part what about ali reason
is definitely putting some pressure no
yes seriously he's putting some pressure
guys yes it's unpleasant Hikaru only 20
seconds what is he thinking wow and he's
being invited to go into a Bishop's
office
so
yeah did you see that reaction by
alireza he saw the result of Fabiano and
he was like ah snap I need to play the
tie breaks now yeah but I tell you tie
breaks have favored him he looked very
good in this tiebreak clash with nepo as
we are about ready to set to Crown a
champion and let's once again inform the
viewers of our playoff rules because
they're going to be playing faster
to a pair of games is that right
Anastasia exactly because the game will
last 10 minutes plus 2 seconds per move
and they'll have to play two games black
and white black and white trap at 916.
okay and then of course back rank same
for both games okay and if it's still
the same score still tight then chess
960 Magazine Game will follow nice five
minutes for white four minutes for black
and if black wins or if black makes draw
then it ends in favor of black and in
the Armageddon game that will be again a
reshuffle uh they won't be playing the
same game that they played in the 10th
plus two games okay that's a nice
playoff scenario and it's gonna be
nervous nervy time and remind us what
the price fund is these guys have been
fighting they've been fighting hard will
they do they split first and second and
there's some extra bonus for winning I
think it's just for the title it's just
for the title so uh Fabi and alireza get
25
000 37 500.
split in half
and now they're playing for
yes
31 200 yes I'm trying to calculate it
was very first good job how did you do
that thank you I only failed College
Oliver twice okay you know this was very
funny in the GMA we were having an
election
and we head to I handicapped the Soviet
boat because there were so many Soviet
players
that Carol jurecki was the teller and
Vichy Anand was also working with her
and why did she because he could
calculate the numbers like that he said
28 percent of the vote went this way 37
percent of the vote went that way 16 of
the vote went this way and none of us
knew it but vishi was a mathematician
whiz wow
his skills right now and now we know
actually what's going on and what do you
think is going on Christian well it is
just a crazy tournament I have to say
and at the beginning of the day given
the fact that alireza was just piling
win after win but first let's go to the
playing hall because Chris bird is
actually talking about the game 5 30.
okay
left it right all right right that you
will have white in game one okay
drawing of lots the games are going to
start at 5 30 p.m and alireza gets white
in the first game yes but the draw sorry
the shuffling of the pieces this the new
position perfect we don't know yet no is
that right no
I won't get as much time as they got for
the regular is that right they're only
going to get 10 minutes plus two seconds
yes
that's a good question something like
that it shouldn't be the same no check
this out like I could imagine Fabby
going and saying okay where are my
troops you know assemble you know like
give me some ideas yeah but there's uh
Ali farouza who's been on his own yeah
but it seems so far so good right
it hasn't worse
last round the games were not decided in
the opening like Hikaru had a great
position out of the opening
and this is the new position okay okay
what do we have we have a queen in the
corner
yes
a rook next to the Queen the King next
to the Rook
another Rook you know in this position
I can tell you what is a fantastic move
opening move castles long really you
Castle on the first move immediately
here's the shuffle
so King goes to B1 what goes to C1 and
then you go like D4 C4 just blast open
the position absolutely unbelievable you
can't sleep I move on I remember if you
shift the king and the Rooks over it was
The Rook was on E1 in one position and
mauricevich has castled on the first
move but Rook on D1 and E1 blasted open
break down this opening position for his
Christian what will the lawyer's
strategy try to be well the problem that
I'm seeing early on in the position is
the Knight on H1 and h8 respectively
um most likely you will get it to G3
nevertheless at that point once you get
the Knight of G3 you will have to worry
about ideas of G6 followed by F5 and
that Knight on G3 is going to be feeling
quite uncomfortable in the position the
queen on A1 that's another problem as
well if you do go A4 and try to get it
via get it out via the third rank the
problem is that you're most likely not
going to Castle on that side anymore
right because weakened the position so
those are the problems that I'm
initially seeing in the first couple of
minutes here and as we can see Fabiano
is uh recruiting some pretty good help
Yes actually and also he tries to get
some energy back
that's nice some chocolate in yes hey
man I gotta compli I mean I I gotta talk
to my agent I went to that ultimate
moves and I went to the Players Lounge
and those guys get much better snacks
than the commentators and I know this I
know they have some berries it has to
stop we also get the budget merch we get
the budget merch right these players get
these huge bags of rice and then we got
this tiny little budget bag
one hat one T-shirt nothing stop it we
will be fired
what is this wow I mean I'm telling you
I mean we are we're being shamed I I
don't get it I don't get it I mean we we
had the most views ever
and we get a cut we're gonna throw
something I actually had this
opportunity to go sometimes to the plane
Hall while you were talking here
there were some fairies and nice
actually stuff yes I must admit that I
have done it yes they had the chocolate
dipped strawberries I don't have any no
chocolate yes you should have told me
before
okay uh we're gonna need some more
training around here but first of all
this final position if Ali Raisa wins
this playoff but what he's already
accomplished is phenomenal just tying
for first
in winning first clear in the rapid and
Blitz tying for first winning the
playoffs tying for first we don't know
about winning the playoffs but if that's
not a Triple Crown you've gotta you
gotta tell me a Christian
yeah well we're going to have to wait
and see whether he manages to do that
but we are here with a very special
guest Gary welcome to the show uh pretty
unfortunate result for you but it seemed
like you are having fun was that the
case yeah maybe I'm having too much fun
um I think there were very high
expectations after my performance last
year here but last year I did some chess
I mean this this year when I arrived
here I just realized that you know I
didn't play chess over the board for a
year and obviously you know the latest
events in Europe you know the war in
Ukraine and this it's it's
uh consume all my energy and attention
and and uh but some games here just made
me feel really good to know okay but of
course of course I wanted to do better
but uh you know looking at these nine
games I would say in six games at least
in six games so this is I missed uh very
good chances so I was better against
Iranian in the end game uh could be even
much better I was winning against
Nakamura I was
at one point winning his Corona I had a
very promising position yesterday that's
that's game that actually made me really
unhappy because you know I sacrificed
The Exchange you know instead of playing
slightly worse position I went for
complications I probably was correct
evaluation and I knew that United Texas
seven was not the best move but
intuitively but I had no time you know
this and I and I spent precious minutes
you know calculating I saw Rook should
go at least three only four I wasn't
sure where you know so and uh computer
prove that August 3 white was slightly
better still part of a draw but black
had to be very very accurate so 97 then
we reach this position I said okay it's
a draw and I managed
I mean how on Earth
and two pawns uh for exchange you know
it's just it's that really yeah it's
it's it was it was really bad and um and
uh and then it was Laos game with Mommy
and actually I was very very uh uh happy
to play the game with Wesley I think
that's one of the most exciting games we
played here the whole tournament and I
did some really good moves and as I
played you know very energetically and
uh and uh it as computer till says that
at one point I was better it's very
close to the end so instead of Laos book
96 King gate and the Wesley may not have
survived so and and today also I just I
had very good position with young very
good position and it's also again it's
it's a lack of practice is there you
know it's this is you know what you want
with your business D1 anything on D1
it's not as good as on D3 so that's why
Bishop city which is a lousy move
because you know what's happened you
know I let him basically to to bring the
knight from C8 and exchange my knight on
G3 so then I just you know after the
game he asked me why they're running for
apologize for a second
plus two second increment
we will play the same position in both
games once we finish this game we'll
have a rest for a couple minutes and
then we'll start game two immediately if
we're still tied at the end of the match
we will go to an Armageddon game which
will be a different position uh we'll
have a drawing of lots immediately and
then you'll both get five minutes to go
over the position before we start the
Armageddon game
it's now time to begin good luck
Gentlemen please go ahead and start
White's clock
Gary I have to ask you one question you
played against Ali Reza from one world
champion to maybe a potential other does
he have what it takes to together well
he definitely you know looks very strong
so it is for his age and I uh will not
be surprised that you know if he makes
it I mean it's uh by every every count
including H so he's just you know he
might be you know the real Contender uh
for for the title naturally he's
outstanding performance here in in this
tournament actually in these tournaments
yeah it's just another proof that he's
really good there's a lot to to to to to
do to work on uh
actually speaking they know this is I
would never play Knight to free closing
the bishop on on on on G1 yeah that's
yeah still still plenty of work today
now that's yeah that's definitely not I
wouldn't recommend maybe that's the
modern way of playing but still I prefer
my vision too to be yeah um so okay I
just you know I I
uh
cherish some memories of this tournament
again I wish you know there's some good
moves I made you know
all over the board during nine games
could be could be made in one or two
games and the blunders you know that
will move to one or two games but again
it's just it happens yes I uh yeah yeah
I have to say that you know it's it's
not recommendable just doing what I did
so I needed to take a bit more seriously
though it was probably impossible uh
these days but
um you know if I if I do it again so I
may uh I may uh change my attitude and
just do a little bit more
are more of uh studies yes
yeah actually I'm just now as we speak
I'm looking at this game
yeah it's an interesting one I guess
because of the D4 I think I think uh at
least I won't play D4 but after A5 it
might be
yeah karwan will remind him that the
king is the king
and I was thinking that maybe alireza
wants to go H4 English page two no no no
the pawn on E5 I think I think D4 that's
that's what's blind but now you saw him
oh he played D4 he played before he
played D4 yes no that's the analysis and
then A5 but after D4 A5 I think he saw
it now and that's that's that's that's
what he's thinking yeah
oh yeah it's uh maybe yeah you should
yes still I just I I hate Bishop one G1
this is this this is certain things you
know as yes I I would not even consider
playing Knight to free
yeah it's a little bit more you know
emphasis on tactics instant tactics you
know but there's certain
yeah actually speaking about before you
know with you know with my Givens are
the result when I just was in symmetry
so instead of playing some lousy moves
like 92 I at one uh in the opening I
could have played before just you know
that's why I didn't play before
we saw you discuss with Ali Reza and it
felt like you almost are giving him some
advice for the future what were you
telling him look you know again I I
think it is I'm not giving advice I'm
just you know it's always nice to talk
to Darwin to actually made a good move
C4 yeah some space for the king yeah it
makes space for the king and it's just
he's playing he's playing for for black
skin yes for yes A5 b55 yeah
look um I'm yeah I think
what Corona will do it's the I think
after King CityPlace E5
so you give the check on a300
no I think you play C5 I mean it's yeah
just you have to press you have to stop
D4 yeah and I think C5 is a natural base
because of the C5 the whole construction
is very odd White Construction so I will
say this is because it was D4 then just
you know his plan is Justified after C5
so not Bishop C5 C5 no oh oh sorry you
can do Bishop of course you know Bishop
C5 Bishop C5 D4 four years yeah but then
you just yeah that's the then you take
taken B6 yes yeah yeah maybe B6
installed next time
he can start with probably B6
attacking E4 spreading space recheck and
queen takes E4
I played Bishop C5 which is also good D4
take take maybe Knight D6
then brother Fred's don't like
University it's t because now white
Bishop somehow will be will be
uh before he's on the board of course
yeah of course on the board yes
so we're most likely going to see take
take
[Music]
you feel Fabiano is having good position
right now
after uh potentially the which spongy
one is going to open up after F3 yes
at the same time
but you are losing some material by
force
um can I take on C4 yeah then then
Queens is free
that's then then then you might be I did
I just I think Bobby had to do something
else because he just let
uh
yeah I thought it was C5 you know after
C5 yeah I probably had to start with B6
attacking the Pokemon D4 and then
playing maybe the bishop said just he
could have because then I literally had
to defend the pawn only four not with D3
maybe exactly no but not with F3 now now
we can play a free yeah
still uh a good position for Fabiano and
some pressure 96 is it played 96 96 is
on the board they're free now yes
can he go Knight D5 after F3 Maybe try
to take without light that's there and
and what about Knight F5
ah then Bishop A3 check oh that's
important it's a check so you should
start with probably Queen C3 and after
you take on C4 I play Knight F5 and then
take your Bishop yeah well we're going
to find out the answer because F3 is on
the board
because Bishop C4 yeah Bishop C4 take
take Queen C3 is definitely calculating
yeah I'm taking the pawn immediately
Knight to E5 is also
95 was probably the 95 Queen City maybe
D6
just you know not to prepare because yes
the king is just you know just
pretentious yes yes could be could be
made so that's why you want you want to
do something just you know because now
my day five night C6 Bishop S3 check
your check so this doesn't work so
that's why you
yeah sir Anastasia
I think uh Fabi has got an advantage
right out of this position and yeah
Gary all the way I thought that Knight
F3 was terrible maybe there was even a
better way of punishing it even so white
is shedding upon and I I like uh the
position Gary um Shack rear said
sometimes it's very easy to lose with
white because you expect to have an
advantage you come and you make a move
like E4 or D4 in the opening and then
you can't justify I bet you put your
bond too far up the board with E4 D4 uh
did you feel that you had an advantage
as white in your games
um look it's yeah so it's very good
question because I think after so many
tournaments of 962 who played here in St
Louis maybe you know someone has to do
little analysis here like forensic
analysis because the position is very
uneven some positions you know are
really challenging so for for black for
instance today in round one on two I
think we had positions that are really
good for white so C4 in game one man I
had Big Adventures with Nepal C4 and B4
and the same actually in second round F4
G4 so that's what what Dominguez did and
it's black is just you know black is
under heavy pressure so um
I I think it's it's this maybe maybe we
need you know we need we need to
probably limit number of positions you
know checking with the computer and
basically leading positions that that
are balanced but I agree with shock that
you know it's so easy for white to to go
wrong because you know sometimes you
know moves like E4 or D4 they may
actually lead to to disadvantage because
because of the awkward position of the
of the pieces so um and that's why it's
very often moves at G4 and B4 are the
best so um it's um it's again it's it's
the the beauty of this game is that you
know what uh from move one you have to
think you know and this is and sometimes
you have positions that are just that or
um that have weaknesses you know this
like yesterday was shocked you know I
got so confused with first move because
polon G7 is hanging and then it'll just
started 9g3 yeah yeah but it's it's
actually it's yeah it's not a big deal
because you know I just I simply could
do symmetry because the attack was you
know but I could have sacrificed the
form and and instead I just I made
actually after E6 default like is lost
so I lost since the game with three
moves so so uh it's oh Fabi Fabian made
a castle
nuts
tucking the king away it's interesting
but it's just I
yeah it's still still pretty pretty
nasty Gary what were you looking at in
these positions when analyzing first
with your team partners uh were you
looking at space Advantage we're looking
at development what was the biggest
factor of assessment that you were
basing your decisions on you know I
think in this this in in this game now
you know space Advantage is very
important uh and uh and that's why you
see so many moves you know the flank
moves A4 B4 G4 H4 so because it's this
is not what happens in In classical jazz
um and I um it's sometimes again you may
have you know the strong content play in
the center but it's uh it's again it's
very very unbalanced so this is first
few moves are so important so it's it's
because typically now we play at 50 20
moves now you know from move one you
have a very very very precise again
it's like you know today you know I I
got big Advantage with white by playing
C4 and B4 and the same happened when I
played against is with F4 G4 and
maybe I could do bad actually at one
point you know I just I I kicked myself
ahead that's after he played H4 I could
have played Knight D4 taking at least
one of his Bishops and creating a little
bit of contemplate and but I just I was
so unhappy with it was him just you know
simply moving you know
I just had to stay you know with my
queen on G8 you know just waiting for
them for the inevitable Gary what's next
for you any uh other tournaments or I
just like look I am and I I know my
limitations and I have so many things to
do now it's the now my next is I go to
Europe now actually tomorrow flight to
New York and and on that sets in the
morning early morning at night go to
Europe so I have several cities to visit
I do lectures and also meet some you
know politicians because it's again it's
uh this is this is a decision moment for
for our civilization and I
I while you know I was unhappy with
what's happened here I was very happy to
see that Ukraine is winning and that's
that's what matters for the humanity not
how many points I I make in the
tournament Gary thank you very much for
joining us and hopefully we'll see you
in let's let's make sure like I'm happy
to to see oh that would be great let's
let's you know because I'm also curious
so what's the what's time control uh
right now is three minutes for Ali Reza
and almost six minutes for Fabiano
doesn't like his kingdom C1 no no that
happens you know when you when you play
before with King on C1 yeah he would
love to Castle short right but there's
three moves to go into you can do that
uh maybe even more like that one two
three four yeah but the problem is you
know C4 Pawn is just it's uh is in big
trouble okay what
what king B2 King B2 he's trying to hide
away A1 A1 at least he was only one was
a king
so uh no Now Pawn is promise upon
how to increase the pressure Knight to
E5 Gary sounds like a natural noise
oh C6 open things up yeah Knight to E5
now we'll plug it in five years
now you know the mission statement of uh
the pond grubbers Gary is upon is a pawn
but you know it's this yeah I know but
uh
how do you take the poem yes sir maybe
slowly
we don't rush we don't rush we're we we
want to make sure that we don't follow
some devilish trick well there's some
Knight of fives coming at some point but
that's what I'm thinking Queen A7 is one
of those moves that really help people
like Bishop before Bishop before first
yeah and then Knight takes C4 yes
yes King A1 Bishop B4
going to see two most likely Knight
takes E4 yeah and Google on C1 I think
he went all the way to C1 yes
he takes C4 Bishop takes C4 at least he
developed the pieces
take them all at least I take C4
5
yes still is the yeah yeah Bishop goes
on D4 now
Brook
all of a sudden yeah you know Queen on
the eight is that's why that's that's
why that's why I was very cautious in
evaluating King on the 8th of King on
eight so you can just white this white
is playing with extra Queen yep and uh
it's uh it's a very serious advantage
well Bishop yeah so do you agree that
Queen is a queen yes Paul there's a pawn
but Queen is a queen
yeah the queen is not uh participating
yeah no Queen is not that's why I think
Fabi had to do better I mean this is the
he actually found a great idea of
bringing on A1
escaped yeah
and Fabi right now actually falling down
to his last four minutes as well
definitely feeling the pressure
Rook takes D7
you'd like to maintain this as for as
long as you can no
this uh okay all right it's probably
correct move
the provocative move she takes
not to simplify things I think that pawn
was taking off no
he goes he goes he goes in the attack he
goes for kill Knight takes you seven
Bishop takes step six
take only four Bishop takes F6 maybe
that's uh
six because Bishops yeah
yeah without with extra Queen you can do
many many nice things many nice things
yeah when you have an extra queen I'm
very strong very strong no uh I'm
feeling the heat Bishop F6 Queen H6
Knight G7 as you say Gary
Bishop F6 uh maybe take on e4 you take
on F6 and now I go Bishop G6 but no the
Knight on C4 is sagging
that's why he went Bishop G6 first
just to stop these ideas of Knight G7
and Bishop F6
G3
and there was your kid I know okay I
know the kids
he's adding pressure is that impression
yeah Knight G3 now now
I don't know maybe C5 he has night
something to be said for C5 97 check
then yeah
but okay it's not the end of the world
and then yeah yeah this is yes well C5
is very natural
because that now you start putting your
piece into play exactly that's the big
problem
eight eight
yes yes
he wants to bring the queen
d8 is going to be a great defender
so alireza has to do something fast and
the times Anastasia
but it's still a little bit too tickling
yes H4
140 one one and a half minutes for early
resin yeah
C5 he has to go C5 yeah okay but because
it's not just you open the position C5
because okay H5 King is protected so the
C5 is important C5 bc6 bc6 and then you
know just another another C5 if
necessary so also C5 secures the Knight
on C4 bc6 bc6 neither CQ yeah yeah so
you don't have to worry anymore about
the Knight and then you can start doing
other things
E6
yeah but that's you know that's the I
want to play C5 without even thinking
yeah yeah so
so now at least why cannot take on D5
anymore because Knight is hanging Fabi
is being very practical with his clock
he is yes he's H5 H5 Bishop 595 Queen is
six 26. because otherwise the command
takes a certain might be a threat yes
what just happened Gary
no King just seven H5 he wants to play
okay
and I said you know black had to
couldn't waste time so he wasted time
can you do 7h5 is that enough though H5
you cannot go Bishop F7 because of Queen
G5 check no that might be a problem
so why are you just wasted time
and now he wants to take on G6 and then
Knight H5 check
and that's the Rook H1 Knight H5 things
are getting murky yeah yeah
Bishop B6 take on Rook H1 yes
Bishop D6
on Rook H1
definitely H5
still probably not saving the Rook H5
yes Queen G5 I feel all three results he
wasn't winning
you think white is winning
Fabiano needs a good move yeah that's
why play C5 you know Play Active moves
well one thing Rook H1 will allow Bishop
D2 so we have a Tempo to do something oh
okay
we have a Tempo to do something I'm not
sure what I'm supposed to do though am I
supposed to play I don't know Queen E6
uh like 2600 take that use the piece ag6
85. now ages six first and then 85 years
yeah yeah
gotta take back because the bishop takes
F6 that's a problem again I suggest C5
yeah C5 C5 then he can do take take a
knight H5 check yeah so
nice and he's playing Knight to E5
closing up that diagonal that seems like
and very quickly came an answer I'm not
sure what it was no there it comes
second G6 take on G6
we're expecting yeah
Reza really wants to open up that
diagonal
C5 yes
C5
no play C5 he will never play C5 it's
oh my gosh C5 yeah so C5 was a good V6
Knight C6 but finally
I'm sure that's the right that's a good
moment right because now the moment
missed was missed see if we change the
Queens tame the position
something tells me is not good no do you
take it back Bishop on D4 now is just as
a killer king yes
King has a very very strong indication
it's all gone A3
South A3
a39 seconds Rook takes b72 93.
and what's the clock time sorry I
understand yes 23 seconds again 15
seconds guys
and just to remind everybody this is the
first of two games they're switching
colors for game two in these playoffs is
a killer rookie trying to cover up the
H1 oh my gosh clock times 11 seconds
okay it's completely winning for white
but
foreign
by the way there's only two seconds
increment not five ah yes maybe they
forgot about it no they didn't no no two
seconds
Knight C2 on Tab and he's done it oh
that's good that's gonna be amazing
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Music]
so I think 51
it's actually yeah four out of four so
far wow we're not worthy we're not
worthy you're oh you're still not over
it's still not very very good people uh
that was a photo finish and the clock
and nerves just about everything played
a role we saw it all there and the crazy
part was way back it looked like Black's
King like right here like look at this
moment
after E5 this is where we're blasting
open white king looks perfectly safe and
after C5 takes it's Black's King who we
think you know is in trouble it's crazy
uh I don't know Christian just I mean
what we saw was nerve-wracking
we still got the Jitters
I do too this Knight a390 ideas I don't
even want to spoil it almost with the
engine and everything that's happening
but what a victory for Fabiano with the
black pieces of crucial Victory
nevertheless sure there is no it almost
feels like there's no opening Advantage
given to the white side in chess 960 so
anything can still happen right Reza can
definitely bounce back in and they play
in the same position that's important I
think yes exactly
actually now you can play the same way
as your opponent and improve it I don't
know it's so tricky wow I don't know
what's happening in the mind of players
I know and unfortunately I I messed up
my my my board like you know what's
funny guys yeah even after Knight to C2
one move before resignation
this position is equal
to say what yes you do I have 95 coming
I'm going to regain my queen back look
at this 95
so one move before resignation this
position was still balanced wow and
perhaps given the presence of the Pawn
on F6 so close to promotion I would
because the Practical chances to White
yes segment is not working yeah
crazy I will take this night but what a
game and they don't get much rest I have
to say no rest for the wicked here the
only one is 12 minutes they're they're
wow they're they're going uh with a
Oops I did something wrong yeah actually
I'm in movie four yes I remember Fabio
was talking with Levon and normally he
says first you check move E4 and then
you try to figure out if it works so if
you can do it right yeah so probably
they came to the conclusion that you can
play like that so E4 is on the board
right now let's remember 10 minutes need
some help with my with my board because
it's just
what I wanted to do
yeah and I will just remind our viewers
that we have 10 minutes for the whole
game yes two seconds guys did you just
see the last move I love it I love it H6
Bishop H7 uh in the previous game he had
the worst bishop ever
and he's going to make sure he's not
going to lose this game with the worst
bishop ever almost feels like you're
with a black side you're playing against
E4 and then your only chance or at least
what you perceive as the only chance to
play for the victory is to play the
mother
it feels like a mother yeah like a purse
well I'm thinking that you play D5 and
if your opponent is so obliging and
plays the French defense then after E5
E6 this bishop is so happy to be outside
of the pawn structure
what could be sweeter playing playing a
French defense with an active Bishop
light squared Bishop
lives in France so probably that's how
he came out exactly and indeed E5 okay
so we're expecting something like E6
followed by C5 and to try to channel the
game into some French defense uh what
kind of motifs this night on E8 by the
way if you're playing a French defense
it's
it needs a new it needs a life well
probably something like the problem with
C5 is that the king becomes so uh
he did that alireza with the white
pieces in the first game and his King
got in big trouble uh-huh and we played
something on the fight all right so he's
playing it like a karaoke he's trying to
get the Knight to G7 and exchange that
via F5 or E6 he's
playing this like a Karo card
with the Knight coming to G6 perhaps yes
um
quite the mixture of ideas that we're
seeing here and as Gary who's with us
through that hold uh first playoff or
tie break game was mentioning the queen
yes stayed on A8 uh did uh fabi's Queen
for quite a while well Bobby's trying to
get that Queen out yes I'm cute A4
you know this queen needs to get out as
soon as possible true true that so let's
get these pieces into play Knight to G7
to E6 or to F5 is mentioned but I like
the night on E6 funnily enough and if I
can get the other Knight to F4 I'm I'm
kind of happy Anastasia
maybe also if for example Loretta was
thinking to play Bishop G7 there is
Queen E3 perhaps the move Bishop let's
say he wanted to develop his Bishop then
E7 will be weak yeah yeah the training
yes
nice okay A7 A5 I'll match and move for
move the one small difference though
that Queen is not coming out to A6
uh if and as you say if the bishop does
leave Queen A3 well I can get mine let's
do it right let's go Queen A3 that's
that's what I'm saying I understand
actually you cannot go E6 because yes
now we can just grab the initial there's
a queen history yes maybe
feels like the very Natural Choice and
again for those of you joining us light
shame on you but Fabi leads 1-0 uh the
best of two if he was played immediately
responded with Knight G7 right
and once more if ferrugia however should
win we will see our first ever
Armageddon 960. they will switch up the
position so it'll be in a new position
and black has draws you know I would
really really rather be black you take
black all day long single day Armageddon
yes I don't know we need to find a
better system because it feels like it's
almost too skewed towards black in that
case exactly by the way very nice crafty
little move here after East 97 we saw F3
E6 it's the little move Queen B3 and
just saying go ahead try to solve your
problems with Knight G5 I've got Bishop
D3 and wait for you and yes you're
welcome to trade and open up the H file
against the bishop and you're welcome to
trade again on my terms
so Bishop of E7 and this is a Prelude
Ali Reza is absolutely ready to you know
what
camera to run away I forgot about that
moment
I really forgot about that yes
it is a funny looking move right the
King goes all the way across the board
yes to G8 by the way Bishop D3 on the
board which left two was played uh
Knight G6 now Bishop D3 oh I see sorry
Bishop F2 was played
96 96 and now Bishop it should be three
Castle
absolutely why not
oh my
okay now I'm starting to feel
a little bit and some danger around my
king on C1 so I would like to I'm
getting jealous of your king I would
like to Castle as well but to do it you
have to move the Knight first yes and
that's the problem that's why he played
C3 probably Knight C2 is the plan and
then short castling too makes sense to
me too I don't want to keep my king
there yeah yeah you better move it I
mean C5 is going to pry open the queen
side for sure so it seems better to have
the king in safety but that's actually a
problem I don't know if you have time
for Knight C2 yes because C5 C4 C5 is so
powerful
well at least I'll have a safe Square
you all your pieces are on the king side
you can't chase me away from B5
are you so sure about that yes sir
because
for example wow yeah I understand and I
get trapped yeah on the B5 screen
getting trapped I mean you still have D7
but
I don't think I want to actually uh so
B7 B6 does set up and this is maybe the
first big thing for Fabby
which surprises me a bit I'm not 100
sure what he wants with that move I
guess C5 is played well he's going to B5
he's and there you go he went to B5 so
Knights so with C4 Bishop C2 Knight E8
this potential trapping of the queen
those moves are on the board
at night it also
98 also yes no 98 is not yet on the
board that you can feel it coming right
there he comes he's on the board now and
now the question is being asked how are
you going to rescue your queen from this
snare and I get it you still have the D7
square foot there is four something like
that no
if we solve problems
well yeah exactly and again if we were
could cast okay let's do it let's just
get our Queen out of Dodge guys this is
really not looking good
really help it help it be through Knight
C7 Queen D7 all right so in the worst
case I can pick up the queen right go to
d8 Rook to d8
going to seven and uh no because you
have Queen C6 but I used to have Queen
C6 all right let's let's try to be
crafty don't be crazy
Queen B7 queen Queen
Bishop takes uh G6 guys yeah yeah
quintex is seven yes
I was waiting for you uh-huh you want
that's why B3 is not a good move Come to
Papa he played B4 by the way B before
okay similar idea just to just to force
you to show your threat right what is
your threat but I wanted to do B3 in
order to now it was a little bit afraid
that after a B I don't get my queen back
I don't think you are
I don't get my queen back but B4 on the
board yes before he's confirmed yes
right now firusha is thinking Fury is
nursing by the way a one minute time
advantage that's huge guys are it feels
dare I say we're heading towards the
armor again yeah
he is spoiled his positions Queen
got lured into Black's camp and once
more let's shall we night okay the
difference here no check is that there's
no check so Bishop takes G6 is a
genuinely yes powerful threat as is uh
Queen takes C7 so in alirez's shoes the
question is instead of Knight C7 let me
take this Pawn that way the queen can't
escape and let me play something of this
nature right preparing Knight C7
the problem is right now after this move
B4 also strategically my Pawn structure
is so good with the black pieces exactly
that's why before I don't know
I like to instead of before so to do
something on the king side like if we
have time if our Queen is not trapped
it's almost like H4 was the idea H5 and
if it takes a four or five maybe seven
almost Five Guys
yeah it just again uh but the problem
with
with both Queen A7 and Rook B7 is the
Knight will hit the queen but the queen
now has a choice of squares and the
thing is I think what he's planning to
do is actually follow it up with Knight
A6 and Knight B4 after that ah so for
example we put an I don't know if this
is a good mover or bad 53 is on the
board yeah this is what's happening
right now but to follow it up as
well we're going to see it guys
I can be stubborn instead of Knight E6
so he's
in this position
thank you but uh
I'm still not okay the problem is I
desperately want a castle kingside but
my knight is is
this infernal night is in the way
um hmm yes sir I mean yes you castling
kingside is not your only problem yeah I
know I know like is the queen I got
issues
I agree I got real issues how will you
trap my queen there is no is it a real
threat like Knight A6 Queen B5 no I
think I'm just going to go Beach Buffet
97.
but if you do that um right yes the king
will be awesome
uh the clock times yeah the clock I
think now if I be thinking for too long
um yeah three three minutes and 40
seconds for Fabiano fight yes
that's a very significant uh difference
on the clock yes very significant and
alireza has the easier position to play
oh my goodness uh he's got so many
tempting moves including B6 B5
uh B6 B5 might be one of those where
your queen gets trapped uh most simply
for example also hold on Rook C8 what
can I do I make a bad move yes B5 uh
takes
oops oops there are so many issues that
could go wrong
oops I think he played King D2
I think King David too yes he did
oops let me get back that one back and
came to D2
where are you today
so what Bishop of Faith or Bishop of
Fate seems like the right move yes
Bishop takes G6 maybe to give up that
picture but still I mean you are
threatening 97 but they have Queen D6
and then what Rook d8 yes
no he says what did he do everything dt5
is on the board yes that was the one I
was worried about B6 B5 looks logical it
takes B5 I don't understood that this
queen A3 is coming so that's why he
played King B2 he wants to buy okay one
sometimes Maybe
well guess what oops
it's a girl okay and now we've got a
rook in the night only we don't have a
pawn no this is just simply this is a
terrible position so we can anticipate
well let's win a pawn with Rook to B8
and let's take it Bishop takes B4 he's
done it oh you want to lose that pawn
well now Queen A3 is coming which was
played
Queen A3 looks like a really this looks
like game over yeah
you know Fabi just decided why not to
play our Magneto it's the first time I
can don't know elf 960 in the history of
Chess and let's say we never had this
fun in my life and our commentators
would have had an easy day we would have
congratulated ourselves and we would be
going home boring but no but no
let's stay around and have some fun
exactly well I have a flight to catch at
nine o'clock so no way where are you
going dude I'm going to Vegas oh the big
fight can we jump with you the big
boxing match I'm going to some fights oh
my goodness yeah yeah hopefully I'll
catch that flight I'm not sure I'm not
sure so what's more violent chess or
boxing chess boxing maybe maybe both
chess box though
like the four was coming right the four
was a big threat you didn't like it
night before coupled with the move C3
that was the problem as gift meet upon
sure why not thank you yeah give it even
though taking the pawn you allow Rook to
A1
maybe you can catch his Queen oh he
wants to he's reaching for the season
looking at C3 right now he's looking at
it
you drew his hand back it's not so bad
two meters against three so
so probably still but we do know that
this is a completely busted position for
sure okay we know but still
25 days of Play It's All About the
nerves right now yes it is so yes it is
so how two minutes drop after three
minutes by the way
what's the follow-up King E2 and then
what
Rook A1 instantly yes it was like Fabi
in intuited had to go for it that had to
kick that Queen away the problem is that
comes at the expense of one Pawn with a
check
yes well there it goes with a check
tonight
five now the Knight on D6 is in peril
certainly is I so Rook b126 that's a
problem
correct one small problem
I don't think that night's coming back I
mean it's it's strange first the queen
got trapped now it appears that the
Knight is getting trapped Rook the A6
that's just the Desperado okay he tries
there will be one and
I mean to do what can you do at this yes
Bishop D6 rugby one you have to fight
until the end
fight die with your good son
I mean Bishop G6 rugby one Queen C3
right and then Rook the six yes that's a
very good question
yes I like that very much what you just
proposed I think that's the best yes and
queen to
c36 was playing he played book districts
and he took on B1 Bishop takes I think
we should look at the bird's eye view
because this is we're playing fast and I
don't think much is happening anymore do
we think it's just over yeah
wow well I've always said one of the
most difficult things in chess is
winning a game but winning on demand
that is uh the mark of a champion and uh
I tell you winning with black
okay here we go
and the two second increment will be in
effect for move 61. okay uh whoever wins
the coin toss
um must immediately choose whether they
want black or black okay before we uh
see the position as soon as we know
who's in we'll let you have to position
you'll have it for five minutes again
okay uh heads or tails
[Applause]
I would correct this ahead why you can't
find people that way
okay this is very interesting so let's
repeat what Chris bird just said says uh
we're gonna print out the game but you
have to call what you want white or
black Bobby won the coin toss he chose
white and he must win the game uh
farouzia will have draw out just up a
few minutes it's all about the time guys
what do you take White
and especially in this matchup between
these two players right in the Nadia
Armageddon but the tie breaks black won
both games exactly why would you choose
white and actually give yourself a
handicap of one minute four minutes to
finish the game against five you only
get those extra couple of seconds after
move 61. I think this is correct key
aspect and the good news is they have
new position I think absolutely new
positions
to conclude the player a little bit a
little bit okay the Bishops on we've
seen this type of with the Knights the
Queens break it down for us Christian
what do you see is an issue once again I
think the Knight on F1 might be an issue
I can see it going to E3 but then again
that's going to accommodate the bishopon
G1 I going to G3 but then the bishop on
each one is going to be uh very
uncomfortable so the Knight on F1 is the
key piece find a way to get that Knight
out and you will be having a favorable
position Knight on F1 deal with that and
well I mean guys it doesn't really
matter at this point right we have a
chess 960 harm together I can tell you
all that is about this position I can
tell you which are the bad pieces and
which ones are not but it will all come
down to nerves tactics tactical
awareness as well is key in this
situation and I have to say I really
dislike this decision by Fabiano to take
the white pieces I will actually let's
say this is a little bit disagree a
little bit um
decided today that either I win this
game or nothing you know like I only he
decided I have to win this game
sometimes it's actually better to play
with this kind of psychology like you
have no choice like you don't play for a
draw you play only for week three but
that's fine black is winning every game
an extra minute downstairs you give
yourself an extra minute win the game
with black no problem nobody's
complaining nobody's complaining uh I I
mean I'd like I like playing The Devil's
Advocate I like being the provocateur
but in truth I'm kind of with with
Christian on this one
because I still believe in my boys
uh but black won both games and pretty
convincingly by the way I'm just looking
at this position and I'm thinking E4 I
heard what you were saying Christian
about bringing the night the night on F1
being a problem piece I want to play E4
put the Knight on E3 and I suddenly
realized there was E4 F5 and this bishop
is sitting A2 so I was like oh man D4 on
the board F5
attacking the pawn on A2 and Knight B3
and
and this is not a mistake as black is
getting a minute less oh wait yes he's
getting a minute yes of course that's
what I I was trying to I was a bit
confused too because five minutes for
white four four black but black has a
broad yes so oh okay then it makes
perfect okay
dude you're not watching the show we
came on the show I asked them I asked
Anastasia break down the playoff rules
for us would you please that was the
first thing she told us am I crazy
it's a general Armageddon yes
black has more time so this is
completely different
huh who decided on that who made the
rules guys
it wasn't Bobby Fisher no way he was
about Bobby Fischer is angry and
visioning this oh my goodness
the decision is perfectly sensible
again well calculated again everybody
loves him yeah everybody
we've got a very early Queen trade as
Ali Raisa saying hey look guys all I
need is a draw let me take the Queens
off the board and uh go into an end game
I think he made a good decision for sure
yes for sure
I mean you haven't made it down you're a
minute down and trying to make 60 moves
you might as well take the Queens off
the board I definitely don't want to see
E4 E5 which would Hammond the bishop on
uh h8 so I'm capturing
I'm capturing on e4 how are you
recapturing with the bishop or the
Knight Anastasia um I I think I'm
already far away from that oh let's see
that's why I think we should stay with
uh the bird's eye yeah it doesn't update
fast enough it's not yeah
so they took on the fortnite is there
Bishop of D5 okay it took Knight takes
Bishop D5 is that the moves that were
played yes and castling law
fumbling stumbling rumbling uh long uh
short castling actually yes but it's
[ __ ] long
strangely enough I actually thought the
King was going to be safe on the C7
square and
something got traded Bishops okay it's
fine it was not it were rocking right
anything in the corner is usually a rook
okay that's castles
and the D5 square is a very healthy
Outpost
foreign
[Music]
it's the commentators bind
uh pawns are on D4 and F4 very unusual
instead of C4 and Evil no it's all about
the time right now if I'll be honest to
maintain his time Edge I don't think he
has any uh Edge in the position anymore
A3 uh do you remember how they got to
this position because I sure don't
okay it updated
it took a long while there for the
update
that's a big decision yes well it's it
sure is nothing on a D6 take everything
yes and the bishop takes recaptures on
E5 everything is being chopped off right
now and for Ali Reza every exchange is
bringing him closer and closer to his
goal but there's a wrong exciting and
now the night is coming to D4 how do you
defend the pawn on C6
I Advance it 96. yes no Knight F6 checks
the Knight on D5 covers F6 is coming in
the problem is how do you continue how
did you get that night out actually yeah
maybe Kingston
rookie six yeah by the way I still like
Black's position yes I like Black's
position yes Rook F3 is possible well
just now black is starting to look good
so you need to player what 92 in order
to save your knight or 95 yes you have
to move your knight here
well does that help Anastasia H6 where
are you going next what H3 right that's
uh that's not exactly what you play for
okay he had to give up the file
uh meaning the e-file and King G7
and Rook D1 the minute Advantage has
almost dissipated right
almost still not there yet still 30
seconds extra guys good and we're only
at move 26. it feels like we've been in
this end game for a while but there's
still 35 movies for Ali Reza before he
gets his extra two seconds exactly by
the way
G5 King F6 I must say it was tempting he
threatens G4 now
yes perhaps now King to F6
now once again uh draw black has draw
odds in these Armageddon games we said
it doesn't matter but now looking at the
position it feels like draw odds are a
big factor a very big factor because I
can see Knight D7 check King E6 and
um
[Music]
uh that's an intriguing defense Rook to
F1 you cannot take on D3 because of
Knight E1 so King E7 and asking you what
you're going to do with the Knight R5
King E7 no he's hesitated 87. it took
him quite a number of time but G4
King D2
G4 is on tap G5 G4 has done it it feels
like the right solution
the five is coming and you have only one
minute left on the clock and we are at
move 33. wow
he touched the Rook but only 50 seconds
time is becoming a big factor right now
three was one possibility instead of and
now it's Bobby that's favored in this
one upon up and extra 40 seconds on his
clock okay
but how do you nurse the extra upon
homes first why not
trade the Rooks
oops and play for the draw by taking
away as many pawns so the exchange pawns
capture first move the Knight that goes
to Jeet that's right Knight
a31 and Knight A3 apologies
21 moves to go come on lady yes the X
for seconds
chocolate
you had very good Training so you think
so this pose bones there it was that was
the move I had expected a moment ago by
the way one okay he's trying to promote
one of those phones but okay that is it
okay that is yes that point is safe on
A5 so that's a good news for Fabian well
King C6 king beef whoops I was expecting
King C6 King B5
he will give up this night before this
Pawn most probably well how do you guys
feel oh yeah who has the better chances
at this moment I think Fabio will take
it yes because now this Pawn that pawn
is coming to A6 and the g Pawn is coming
as well
wow A6
on the Square I don't think you're in
time right now go G5 I gotta come back
with the King 95 King G4 King F6 still
eight moves to go oh he's gonna come
back five he's going on the other side
Knight takes C4
might be winning right now wow and he
finds it nice King B5 no no he played it
let's wait take the pawn oh my goodness
the Knight is back in time
because Possible Oh Knight D6 and nights
my goodness this is a temple save this I
cannot believe it
I think he's saving this it's almost a
Zeus one
oops
Knight F6 and that's a Susan
wow
what's a game
he's smiling as well he knew that I'm
rooting for him you know choose him and
even our producer Tom wait is that a six
one yeah
is going on was there any question
there he is our champion yes nine LX
wins the tournament and he gets 31 250
dollars Christian you were right thank
you in calculations yeah it is uh sharp
well I mean every truth be told I would
be happy for anybody who won the event
whether it be Alois or Shack but I'm
thinking most especially for Fabi he
needs this he's had he's had a bad run
let's face a Christian he's had a bad
run from the Olympia from the candidates
and this is something he can build on no
absolutely I think this was crucial I
think a good result and uh for the first
time after many many years we worked
together in the singfield cup and I was
seeing some positive uh news coming from
his Camp as well and from his training
going into the singfield cup he showed
that he can definitely fight and be back
in the top five in that tournament he
finished on past one so that was a
positive result for him and of course
this is crucial this victory in just 19
it doesn't matter that it's not
classical chess or rapid and Blitz or
it's just 960 just 9 LX and it
definitely matters any tournament
Victory matters because confidence is
key at this point confidence is very
often the thing that separates this
Champions so it's definitely very very
important for him that's exactly the way
I felt and here is how we finish that
let's go through our roster of players
uh
[Music]
both of them had six points half a point
behind nice and then Wesley saw with
four and a half
has four points the car on the Commodore
also four and then Peter sweetler and
linear Domingos for three and a half and
garika's part of half a point absolutely
the seven and a half as we get our
guests in studio Anastasia let's just
break it down for our audience uh but we
are ready we are ready I wanted to thank
everybody at the St Louis chess club but
first of all alireza is with Christian
Oliver first of all congratulations what
a Titanic struggle you tried to get the
hat-trick but in the end in that
Armageddon it didn't happen at the same
time even after that loss you are still
smiling take us through your feelings
right now yes it's I had hat trick I won
GCT singfield and St Louis so that's a
hat trick yeah this was quadruple but
yeah no Fabian played very well today so
um he beat Wesley and yeah then I think
he deserved to win the tournament how
did you feel uh today's rounds take us
through the first three rounds I played
well I missed a lot of chances I think
against Hikaru I should just play for
win and forget about drama I think it
was much better but the first round I
almost
mad about because against Peter it was
just completely winning I think just F3
was winning and then instead of FG so it
was yeah so yeah I I completely okay it
was very tired today also so I'm happy
that I managed to go to the tour break
at least but still in the tie breaks you
actually won On Demand with the black
pieces and you started off with that
enterprising H6 how did you come up to
that yeah that conclusion yeah it's uh I
understood immediately that it's kind of
coral composition to get the bishop on
H7 and push D5 looked very interesting
probably it's not the best way but it
looked very interesting and I played
very well that game so but yeah I
normally I don't know this was just a
mess so I cannot be sad about it still
uh very successful trip to St Louis yeah
sum it up for us
yeah it was a great
events here everything was very high
level
um really it's Saint Louis is a great
City I think when I when we came here
with family we were very comfortable
from the beginning and
uh it kind of felt like home events so
the hotel was good the plane condition
was great so it's one of my favorite
places now and it's and my chest was I
think very good
um I think I lost only two games in the
whole three events so that was a good
performance but in general
um yeah I'm very happy I hope to be back
here and yeah it could have been it
could have couldn't have been better
alirez a big congratulations for you we
definitely hope to see you soon here in
St Louis congratulations thanks and our
congratulations as well indeed uh Ali
razor wonderful wonderful performance he
will return to France a very very happy
man I mean he has done something uh
quite shocking and unprecedented in
chess winning three uh events in a row
or at least tying for three events in a
row because yes
we do have the wiener the real winner by
tie breaks uh getting set up in studio
and also we just as we as we're winding
down our shows we really do want to say
how grateful we are to our St Louis
chess club and Scholastic Center for all
of the hosting they do they they're
wonderful they take really really good
care of is and we're going to shoot back
to Christian and Fabi Fabiano
congratulations a huge important victory
for you chess nine elex how do you feel
right now no this feels great of course
uh
I mean even though it was a total mess
of a playoff
um and it was super difficult and uh
honestly I was very lucky in the last
game in Armageddon and also in the first
game uh still I feel very happy
sum it up for us what are your feelings
right now after this important victory
for you what were the things that you
enjoyed the most about this tournament
well it was overall fun
um and the last day was especially good
because I didn't think I had any chance
to win
um with three rounds to go and so many
people ahead of me and so much catching
up to but all the games went well today
and how about the tie breaks how did you
leave well race you started off with a
nice clean Victory well clean
yeah no the thing is once you get down
like I assume from the opening I was
borderline winning and then it became a
total mess and I'm sure I was losing at
some point I'm like there's no doubt
that in the time scramble at some point
I was dead lost and then he blundered
mate in a position where I might still
be losing after Quincy so I'm not sure
but definitely a few years before I was
lost but once you get down to um
a two second increment it's like it's
only enough time to physically make the
move you can actually think about the
position it's not like online where
things go A bit a bit faster uh so two
seconds is just enough not to flag
so of course the quality like once you
get there there's zero it's like we're
beginners playing pretty much
and uh yeah then he played a great
second game
um
I forgot he can Castle short we did too
when he did I was like oh no my my
position is collapsed it's quite bad
already and uh maybe E5 was Impractical
um because then we get this really
really tough protracted fight and and
with such a Time control you know it's
uh it'll go out of control at some point
um and then okay I thought white I
wasn't sure but I thought I'll just go
with white in the Armageddon you have to
take white right specifically because of
the time Advantage yeah but one minute
is not that much and you don't really
like I think it's pretty much equal from
opening because you're both on your own
it's just like a new position for both
players so the wide Advantage is very
minimal but I I thought it okay Ali Reza
will probably flag me if I take black so
I I thought I'll take my chances with
white instead Fabiano you have uh so
many fans around the world any final
thoughts for uh them
um well you know now I have a new job as
a chess podcaster so I guess sorry I've
become an amateur chess player so it's
good to still be able to play well well
definitely played well congratulations
on this big tournament Victory and well
we're looking forward to see you in the
US Championship thank you our
congratulations congratulations as well
Papi it was really a a great deal of fun
calling your games in fact everybody's
games but uh uh the the incredible
number of decisive games in the
tournament
at this moment I think that's one of the
things that makes it so much nicer for
us as commentators because every day
there was so much action and pieces
getting thrown around Christian you're
your take on the decisive uh in The
Showdown this is nice number of games we
had so many decisive games in the St
Louis rapid and Blitz and we followed it
up nicely here at the chess 9lx I have
to say I had a lot of fun casting the
games with you guys I know my job is
generally to look at the engine but I
was trying to not peek at it at all
because I was having so much fun
analyzing in the players as well that's
what they said when they first came for
their interviews in the first day we
enjoy seeing new friends positions so
I'm definitely enjoying this format and
I hope to see more tournaments and of
course it was such a pleasure to once
again be back in the casting Booth with
you Anastasia with you Yasser you guys
are on camera right now
I'm a Christian
don't invite Christians
it was yeah and let's go through uh the
roster of players uh starting with our
10th Place finisher Anastasia exactly so
we have Gary Gasparov who took the dance
place and seven and a half came home
exactly and in a ninth position nice
position called Peter swiller who woke
up last days and he takes seven and a
half also tying time for the eighth
place with
[Music]
the tournament Defender yes linear
Dominguez
he was defending
this title and this is returning
Champion I should say and then seventh
we have
inside actually for sixth place together
with
Nakamura
you have yeah he started oh yes it was
not good but then actually the second
day was great but today it was not so it
wasn't his day yes on the draw was
salireza exactly
and then we have Wesley so my pick yes
our reigning world champion in Fisher
960. you'll be trying to defend his
title uh in Reykjavik and in the fourth
position in the fourth position we have
Shakira we should give time for the
sword and he played really well with
this event he really did he had that 4-0
streak that was very impressive had us
all a buzz
and the players started with Incredible
4-0 streak exactly
and yes he was the leader actually after
the first day he made three out of three
at the end he finished on the third
place and has 17 won 17 500 our
congratulations to Yan he really enjoyed
calling your game and our boy was
wondering yes 31 000 I mean not bad at
all fantastic
a name we will be repeating for many
many years to come but all hail the
champion and Fabiano caruana yes he won
the tournament he fought like a lion
maybe I like very much the way he played
and handled it in the last game yeah it
was great
and uh Christian over to you as uh
yes things were perfect that's great I
mean well I just wanted to say once
again uh to our great thanks to the
people here at the St Louis chess club
at Scholastic Center you really really
do make coming to St Louis fun uh
commentating especially so I love the
production team love working with them
even as we insult them uh backwards and
forwards you guys are great you know I'm
talking about Tommy and varuja always in
the keeping us on our toes and to your
Anastasia seriously it was wonderful
wonderful
calling the action alongside you you
were terrific really thank you yes sir I
mean it's such a pleasure it will be
here with the best commentator in the
world oh get out of here and to
yourselves thank you so much for sharing
your day with us and uh joining our show
we're gonna be back next month for the
U.S championships they will be the
national championships for the open
national championships as well as the
ladies don't you miss it tell your
friends where you're hanging hanging out
and we'll see you then
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is prohibited